here we go and boom we're a lot Graham
great to see you again nice to meet you
I mean we were just talking about your
new book America before that there's two
versions of it there's one version and
then there's a newer version that's a
barnes & noble version that's specific
to Barnes & Noble that has an extra
whole chapter in it that's correct
yeah yeah and so they can get that at
Barnes & Noble I'm just trying to keep
bookstores alive man I think it's really
important and that's that's one of the
reasons that I did this because because
I I had finished the book and then
Barnes and Noble came to me through my
publishers and and said they would like
to do a special edition of the book but
in order to do that I needed to write
them some extra material and and I had a
lot of material that I hadn't put in the
book and I thought well this is an
opportunity to put that out there
beautiful so if people want that it's a
little bit different and there's a small
gold well okay so first of all my
website Graham Hancock com has a page
about America before and the link to the
Barnes & Noble Edition is there as well
as the link to the standard edition
which is on Amazon and iTunes and all
kinds of all kinds of other places so
Graham Hancock comm and the America
before page the link to the Barnes &
Noble Edition is right there alright
there it is
so how was this before we even get into
what is it go to talks and events okay
we're on the Graham hunt website I'll go
to books books go to America before
bamm-bamm go to United States you can
see Amazon mods and there's Barnes &
Noble special edition special edition
click on that there you go and then the
e-book as well the label the audiobook
which I read myself X is available there
that if you scroll down oops I shouldn't
be there damn pop-ups damages I am so
happy you read it yourself I get angry
when someone else reads someone who I'm
like come on he can talk yeah I enjoy
reading my books myself and and what
I've what I've learned from feedback I
get from audiences at presentations is
people like me doing that oh yeah for
sure yeah yeah and a hundred percent
it's just weird when someone else is
talking in your voice like a man I know
you
you know that I write fiction as well as
the unsession yeah and the one thing I
can't read is my fiction really well
yeah because fictions requires accents
you read need an actor to read a fiction
book who can get into the different
characters but for a nonfiction book
like American before it's very
straightforward for you just to read it
myself I agree I'm a tremendous Stephen
King fan but when I read Stephen King's
books where he reads them or listen to
him when he reads them they're terrible
he's awful at it should should read
there of their own novels I think that's
it that's a job for foreign actor oddly
enough I've just been reading Stephen
King's Dark Tower series yeah very near
the end of the seventh volume of that
yeah I'm just a giant fan of his but
when he reads it he reads it like he's
just reading it yeah it's like oh this
is rough it's hard to get behind anyway
America before so there's the give us a
website there's there's details about
the book there's a page where there are
links to the book and also the other
thing I would like to take this
opportunity to mention is I'm in America
and Canada for the next seven weeks and
I'm going to be doing something like 25
presentations in something like 20
American cities and then three Canadian
cities in in Vancouver Montreal and
Toronto and that's all on the talks and
events page of my website so if anybody
wants to come along and meet this old
man in person I will be Alvie doing
those events I know doing these are
theatres and do you allow Q&A cycle
absolutely absolutely I allow I allow
Q&A so I encourage that I I feel as an
author that frankly speaking I'm nothing
without my audience
I owe my audience my readers big time
and what I try to do at events is to
give back as much as I can so if people
want to take pictures with me I am
absolutely up for that I don't
understand why anybody wouldn't want to
do that but it's fun it's kind of fun
and what people want to come to the desk
where I'm signing and ask me personal
questions I'm ready to do that sometimes
on the British book tour which I just
finished I was behind in the in the
event space for four hours after the
event finished Wow
signing and taking and taking pictures
but it's a joy it's a really opportunity
for me to interact with with with the
people who actually make my work matters
that's fantastic beautiful so what
inspired this I know there's there's
always been
you first of all we should just say for
people who don't know you have been at
the front of the line for decades
talking about these lost civilizations
and I from reading your work I mean I
think I first read your work in the 90s
you exposed me to a lot of these what
were at the time controversial ideas
that have now been substantiated by
actual evidence particularly gobekli
tepe and i mean the the the all the
water erosion stuff on the Sphinx and
I've since had dr. Robert Schoch on the
podcast to talk about that as well but
all this stuff was at one point very
controversial and now far less yes I
mean whatever traditional academics and
traditional historians that are trying
to against archeologists that we're
trying to resist they've let go a lot of
that they've had to with things like
Gobekli tap they've had to because the
evidence has overwhelmed them and
gobekli tepe is an excellent example
prior to the discovery and excavation of
Quebec the Tepe which is a site in
Anatolia in Turkey it was the view very
firm view of archaeologists that there
had been no megalithic architecture
anywhere on earth and when I say
megalithic I mean literally big stones
stone circles huge constructions nothing
like that before
at the very very earliest 6,000 years
ago and they would point to sites in for
example Malta a site called gigantea
which is about 5,800 years or this that
that's the oldest megalithic
architecture in the world and they could
understand how that was because these
were agricultural societies they
generated surpluses you could free up
people who could become specialists in
architecture in astronomy in geometry
and they could apply their skills to the
construction of these sites but what
they never considered possible was that
a society that was hunter-gatherers
would have created a gigantic megalithic
site and then suddenly gobekli tepe is
discovered it dates to eleven thousand
six hundred years ago it's more than
five thousand years older than the
supposedly oldest megalithic
architecture in the world and it is in
the center where there had been no
previous evidence of agriculture but the
moment go back in Tepe appears
agriculture appears as well and this is
just something that's really hard for
archaeology to explain they've suddenly
got five
thousand years of missing of missing
history that they've just never taken
into account and what I see them doing
is largely avoiding the problem rather
than getting getting to grips with it
directly and in fact there have been
there have been a great number of
changes in the last twenty years which
which have worked generally in favor of
the arguments that I've that I've
proposed well I'm so happy for you
because I know that for a long time you
were out there on your own okay a lot of
these theories very very much so and and
also subjected to the most the most
blistering and deeply unpleasant
criticism from from the archaeological
fraternity and from their friends in the
in in the media like how dare this
journalist proposed that history might
be different than that we might have a
forgotten chapter in the human story it
was regarded almost as offensive that I
would put this material out there and
archaeologists felt it was their
responsibility to show the public that I
was full of [ __ ] and that was and that
was the whole way my work was was
greeted and in to a certain extent still
is greeted by archaeologists but things
have changed central to my work was the
notion of a global Cataclysm roughly
twelve thousand five hundred twelve
thousand eight hundred years ago there
was it made sense to me in 1995 when I
wrote fingerprints of the gods but there
was no compelling evidence for a global
Cataclysm then I just had all the
evidence seemed to point to that time
and a massive global event and then from
2007 onwards you know more than a decade
after I wrote fingerprints of the gods
we get a group of more than 60 major
scientists who are seriously proposing
that the earth was hit by multiple
fragments of a giant comet twelve
thousand eight hundred years ago and
that this caused a huge rise in sea
level and extinctions of megafauna 's
they are not saying that it also wiped
out a lost advanced civilization of
prehistory I'm saying that yeah but but
what what has changed is that we now
have compelling hard scientific evidence
I'm not saying every scientist accepts
it it's the nature of science to dispute
findings but we have a group of 60 major
figures who have seriously proposed this
in all the leading mainstream journals
and it's changed the balance of power in
this in this argument because one thing
that they used to say is Hancock can't
be right because there was no glow
Cataclysm you know twelve or thirteen
thousand years ago well now we know
there was and there are various
explanations for it so that's moved
things along and the other thing that's
changed a lot is the attitude of the man
in the street to Authority that has
changed back in the 90s authority
figures were the gatekeepers they
controlled everything of an authority
figure in a discipline like archaeology
said Hancock is completely wrong he's
made all this stuff up that would
generally be believed not by everybody
but by the majority of people today to
have a mainstream authority figure say
that to me is actually an advantage
because people are so distrustful of
authority and rightly so because we've
been lied to by authority figures in all
fields for so long the [ __ ] has been
so enormous that people are finally
waking up but we can't trust what
authority figures say and I think we can
thank the internet for that we can thank
the internet you I'm sure you've seen
the more recent evidence of a crater
that they just discovered like fairly
recently in Greenland yes enormous
it's an enormous crater it's 18 miles
wide it had not been discovered before
because it's under ice it's under a lot
of ice at the end of the Ice Age
Greenland was one area which never lost
its ice covered completely whereas North
America everywhere north of Minnesota
was covered in ice a mile sometimes two
miles deep Europe the same northern
Europe but Greenland kept its ice
whereas the other parts of the world
lost their ice at the at the end of the
Ice Age and what's interesting about
Greenland is there's already evidence of
comet impact in Greenland which goes
back to papers published in the
Proceedings of the National Academy of
Sciences in 2013 that they found what
are called impact proxies in Greenland
in other words nano diamonds Carbon
spherules are not evidence of a lot of
platinum and an iron was found in a
layer in the ice dated to twelve
thousand eight hundred years ago but the
next development that you're absolutely
right and this was just a few months ago
was the discovery of this humongous
crater in Greenland and an evidence that
it was caused by an iron impactor of
some kind now dating of it I would be
irresponsible to say that that crater
definitely dates to 12
thousand eight hundred years ago because
the work has not been done to prove that
yet but what I can say and what the
specialists who have explored and
excavated the crater are saying is that
it's recent they can say for sure that
it happened during the last ice age
under it under the crater is nothing but
massively disturbed and destroyed and
completely wrecked ice from the ice edge
from the Pleistocene above it is smooth
perfect ice from our epoch which is
called the Holocene which began about
eleven thousand six hundred years ago so
all the evidence suggests that this
created dates to that period between
twelve thousand eight hundred and eleven
thousand six hundred years ago but to
absolutely confirm that more work needs
to be done but it's part of a growing
pattern the Younger Dryas impact
scientists they they call themselves
that they call this the Younger Dryas
impact hypothesis and it's because there
was a period in in the Earth's
geological history that geologists call
the Younger Dryas which lasted for 1,200
years from twelve thousand eight hundred
to eleven thousand six hundred years ago
it's a very mysterious period we see all
the megafauna dying off suddenly and
rapidly we see rises in sea level we see
huge collapse in global temperature it's
a it's a cataclysmic epoch and and what
what what is becoming clearer and and
clearer is that the evidence that a
comet behind it was behind it is it is
extremely strong and as more and more
evidence comes in we realize how
widespread it was so they found evidence
of the impacts as far south as
Antarctica now previously they were
focused very much on North America now
as far south as Antarctica as far east
as Syria this was truly a global a
global event and and it changed the
world and I think and it's my case that
it wiped our memory of a previous
episode of human civilization that right
at the epicenter of this Cataclysm was a
civilization that we would regard as
advanced not a simple hunter-gatherer
civilization which was utterly wiped out
in this cataclysmic event and I should
say for anyone who's really fascinated
right now please maybe pause and go
listen to the one that the two that you
did with Randall Carlson yes where
really goes into depth about
the impact the evidence of these impacts
the evidence of the very quick demise of
the ice age and what may have resulted
in all these floods that you read about
in the epic of gilgamesh that you read
about a Noah's Ark and that all these
things are probably tales that of
stories that people passed down from
generation to generation that survived
this time yeah because we now know that
at that time between 12 thousand eight
hundred and eleven thousand six hundred
years ago truly global cataclysmic
events involving rapid rises in sea
level yea did occur and suddenly the the
worldwide tradition of a of a global
flood stops being just a myth and starts
being a memory the own account of real
events it's been my privilege to work
very closely with Randall Carlson yeah
he's around is absolutely amazing he is
a total genius he's also a gentle giant
and such a kind generous spirited person
it's a joy to work with him and every
minute spent with him is in education I
had the privilege of travelling across
the channel scablands in Washington
State with Randall and seeing things
through his eyes really opened my eyes
to the scale of this disaster you know
you could look at these giant boulders
called glacial erratics and they just
look odd sitting there in the landscape
but when you really consider how they
got there that they got there in
icebergs the size of oil tankers that
were carried on floods that were at
least 500 up to a thousand feet deep
that were tearing through the channeled
scablands literally ripping the
landscape apart then the icebergs would
ground on valley sides the flood waters
would receive the icebergs would be left
there giant icebergs and as they melted
away they revealed the rocks that they
hadn't chained that were caught up
within them and they're scattered all
over the landscape and you look at that
and you think anything that was
underneath that twelve thousand eight
hundred years ago is gone completely
there can't be anything left of it at
all utterly utterly destroyed and I
would encourage people that are
interested in this too please watch the
youtube videos of it because Randall
provides all sorts of video and
photographic evidence where you can take
a look at the landscape and you get a
perspective of how immense this
destruction was yeah it's it's really
it's really important to to see that
because it's easy enough to talk about
floods and and cataclysms but actually
to see its effect on the landscape
directly is
it has an emotional and emotional impact
I felt I felt emotional traveling
traveling across the channel scablands
real realizing that this was was the
heart of an event that changed the world
completely and the evidence continues to
build I have in America before I've not
gone over old ground that I went over in
magicians of the gods that we covered in
the various interviews and podcasts in
which it's really a good idea that
people take a look at but I what I have
done is added the new information
published since 2015 which further
supports the Younger Dryas impact
hypothesis and the notion that multiple
fragments of a giant comet hit the earth
and and created a absolute global
catastrophe so what was the motivation
behind creating this book America before
it's a curious mixture of things I have
been exploring the possibility of a lost
civilization for more than 25 years that
was the essence of my book fingerprints
of the gods that was published in 1995
that there has been a huge forgotten
episode in human history I continued to
follow that in a series of other books
and by the time I got to 2002 when I
published a book called underworld that
followed seven years of scuba diving on
continental shelves looking for
structures that were submerged by rising
sea levels at the end of the last ice
age I really felt I'd done it I felt I'd
walked the walk I'd put put out to the
public a massive body of information and
I thought my role in this is over and I
can breathe a sigh of relief because
it's hot in this particular kitchen and
I can go do something else and I ended
up writing a book about psychedelics I
ended up writing supernatural meetings
with the ancient teachers of mankind
about the role of psychedelics in in the
origins of the of the human story but
then new information started to come out
that touched on the lost civilization
idea and I couldn't just stand by and
ignore that information that's why I
published magicians of the gods in 2015
and then as I was researching that book
I became aware of something I hadn't
realized before that there's a mass of
new information from the Americas
specifically from the Americas which
completely rewrites the story of human
history that the
Americas have been misrepresented for a
very long time by archeology and
archaeologists will be annoyed with me
for saying that they have a way of
forgetting their own arrows of saying oh
well we knew that all along it wasn't it
wasn't the case but the fact of the
matter remains that for best part of 50
years from the 1960s through until about
2010 American archeology was locked in a
dogma that they actually had a name for
which was Clovis first that they
invented a name for a culture they
called them the Clovis culture we don't
know what they called themselves they
were hunter-gatherers they first appear
in the archaeological record thirteen
thousand four hundred years ago and they
vanished from the archaeological record
twelve thousand six hundred years ago
and for a very long time it was
maintained adamantly that these were the
first Americans that no human being
touched the soil of the Americas until
thirteen thousand four hundred years ago
just animals but no human beings present
at all and any archaeologists who
attempted to dispute that dogma and I
used the word deliberately there should
be no room for dogma in science but any
archaeologists who challenged that would
face severe problems with his or her
career they would be mocked and
humiliated at conferences like an
archaeologist called Jax Hank Mars from
from Canada who excavated in the in the
in the Yukon humiliated at conferences
insulted accused of making stuff up
their research funding would be
withdrawn basically to challenge Clovis
first was the end of your archaeological
career so naturally very few
archaeologists wanted to challenge
Clovis first what was this gentleman in
the Yukon was he's called Jacques sank
Mars and interestingly the Smithsonian
just in 2017 did a big kind of Maher
culpa
big admission about this that everybody
had got things wrong that Jack sank Mars
had been ruined by the Clovis first
Lobby but he'd been right all along the
site he excavated in the Yukon was
reacts cavae today 2017 and every single
thing he said was correct even though
they had just sneered at him
where was he he was excavating in the
1980s and the 1990s he's still alive
he's still alive yeah yeah
well I think he's vindicated you know
and it's kind of it's kind of nice to be
vindicated that there's almost a place
in folklore folklore for the firm for
the individual who is scorned and
humiliated you know by by others but who
turns out to be to be right and he and
he was right but my point about this is
that what it meant was since it was the
dogma that Clovis was first that they
oldest dates were thirteen thousand four
hundred years ago there seemed to be no
logic to archaeologists in digging
deeper you know how it is with
archaeology that the the upper levels
are the youngest and the deeper you go
the older it gets that's why we say
Upper Paleolithic for the late Ice Age
and lower Paleolithic for further late
Stone Age and lower for the older Stone
Age and the feeling was no need to dig
below the clovis layer because we
already know that there were no human
beings then before that and then a few
archaeologists I've mentioned Jack's on
Mars but but another is Al gujiya from
the University of South Carolina who
excavated a site called topper in South
Carolina now topper is an incredibly
rich Clovis site it's full of their
tools their points they made these
special special flint points that we
used as arrowheads and Spears great
Clovis site he finished excavating the
Clovis level and then he did something
that was supposed not to be done he
decided to dig deeper and he carried on
Deeping down digging down and there was
a layer of about a meter and a half of
barren soil and then beneath that more
human artifacts and they finally date
those back to more than 50 thousand
years ago and then in 2017 published in
nature by Tom de Maury who's the chief
paleontologist at the San Diego Natural
History Museum and a bunch of other very
high-level paleontologists published in
nature magazine evidence for human
presence in North America 130,000 years
ago now this has really put the cat
amongst the pigeons now if humans were
depressed North America a hundred and
thirty thousand years ago and
archaeologists have been telling us for
fifty years that they were only present
from 13,000 years ago that's ten times
as long that we've had humans in North
America capable of doing stuff and the
archaeological dogma has prevented any
search
what they were doing and we'll until
very recently what was the evidence from
130,000 years ago okay so what it's not
the let me be clear about this because
because this is this is something that
is often misrepresented in in my views
it is not the evidence for an advanced
civilization that we find 130,000 years
ago in America the evidence that we find
is evidence for human presence and what
they were doing was very much stone age
stuff it's a mastodon it's a Mastodon
skeleton that was that was excavated it
was actually found by accident during
road construction near near San Diego
and and an archaeologist was attached to
the road construction crew and
immediately stopped construction and
they investigated it thoroughly and what
they found was so much dynamite in the
early 1990s when they found it that they
decided not to publish at the time
because what they found was evidence
that those Mastodon bones had been
cracked open by human beings using tools
and that the marrow had been extracted
that one tusk had been left standing
upright in the ground and another had
been left beside it that femur had a
femur of the animal had been taken away
completely from the site and there was
assemblages of instruments that were
used to smash and break the bones and
the conclusion of the team was that only
one kind of creature could have done
that work using tools on a mastodon and
that's human beings that's classic
classic human behavior so this sets the
goal posts in a totally different place
suddenly we have to consider that humans
have been in America for a hundred and
thirty thousand years we already know
that a dogmatic approach of archaeology
has rather refused to look at anything
older than 13,000 years ago and what it
does is it generates an engine of demand
that we need to be looking at those
missing hundred thousand plus years we
need to be looking at it hard of course
the immediate reaction has not been to
go looking for stuff in the other
hundred thousand years most
archeologists have responded by saying
this is impossible it can't be it can't
be so but that's precisely what they
said - Jacque sank Mars who said that
humans were in Bluefish caves in the
Yukon twenty-five thousand years ago and
it's precisely what they said to our
Goodyear who said humans had been at
topper fifty thousand years ago and they
were both right and
I believe that Tom Demery and his team
you don't get a big article published in
nature unless it's already pretty
solidly based and pretty much peer
reviews it has produced a reaction I
would be wrong to say that it's
universally accepted it's very much
challenged what is intriguing what is
the challenge the challenge
fundamentally comes from we
archeologists know that there were no
human beings in the Americas that far
back to put it in perspective it's about
sixty thousand years before the first
evidence of human beings in Europe it's
about sixty thousand years before the
first evidence of human beings in
Australia and this is just evidence or
the first human beings yes we have to
point out how difficult it is to find
evidence extremely difficult to find you
know sometimes we imagine that
archaeologists are working with masses
of skeletal material though they're not
and they're not I mean the whole this is
one of the ironies the whole Clovis
first Dogma you would think that they
had masses of material to work with they
did have the tools but in terms of
skeletal remains just one just one
single skeletal remains from now one of
the things that Michael Shermer had sent
me was this dispute that perhaps the
bones had been cracked open by the
excavation material yeah I see
excavation machines
I saw Michaels email email last night
and I I appreciate that Michael wants to
continue to engage with this subject and
that's his job he's a professional
skeptic and and it's his role to do so
but what he what he misses out it's true
that a new paper has been published
which raises questions over the what's
called the cerruti Mastodon site which
is the site that Tom Desmarais at San
Diego Natural History Museum excavated
and what's interesting since I can since
Michael took the trouble to write the
questions can I just sure I just read
you something that I responded to on
this sure which is that to the
microphone oh yeah yeah bass basically
this this this paper was in no way a
refutation of the original paper in
nature as a matter of fact the gentleman
who wrote that paper never even looked
at the archaeological remains that are
in that now in the San Diego Natural
History Museum
what it is what he based it on is
reference I'm quoting from the abstract
of the paper itself reference to a
freeway right-of-way map and
construction plans Contemporary Road
building practices and worksite
photographs available on the Internet
in other words the site was not visited
they simply looked at secondary
references they did not look at the
archaeological material and they ignored
the entire argument of Tom dem RA and
his colleagues who had already addressed
that issue they didn't look at the bones
they did not look at the bones when you
when you break a fresh bone it has a
characteristic kind of spiral fracture
that does not happen when you break a
fossilized bone and Tom dem array and
his team specifically ruled out road
making machinery as responsible for this
breaking pattern because they actually
carried out experiments on modern
elephants deceased elephants and they
broke their bones and the kind of
fracture that you get in a fresh green
bone is completely different from the
kind of flexure you get in a in a in a
fossilized bone so unfortunately this
paper pays pays no attention to that it
just looks at road plans and says there
was road work there it must have been
done by road work and it's very sloppy
very weak and it's certainly not the
answer we can expect ongoing debate and
that is that is healthy but this is not
a strong case at all
so this points to the first evidence
that we found and is there any effort
underway to try to uncover more evidence
that from a similar type well I'm I'm
going to cite Tom Tom decorated the
chief paleontologist the San Diego
Natural History Museum that's what he
would like to see he makes the point to
me I interview him I spent a day with
him at the Natural History Museum he was
very generous with his time I did an
extended interview and I quote from it
in in America before and his wish is
that archeologists instead of spending
all their time trying to find ways to
dismiss and get rid of his findings his
wish is that they would spend a little
bit of that time looking at deposits
older than thirteen thousand four
hundred years and even being willing to
go back as far as a hundred and thirty
thousand years that's that's would be a
proper scientific response here is a
thorough body of work put forward by a
very senior group of scientists who
hesitated before they put
they had the information back in the
1990s but it wasn't until refined dating
techniques later than in the 21st
century that they finally work sure what
they had and that they published it in
in nature in 2017 it's it's it's an it's
an important study and and I think
what's going to happen is that we're
going to find much more evidence of a
very ancient human presence in the
america americas and that's what tom
Demery thinks as well and as he points
out if we don't look then we're never
going to find if we allow dogma to stop
us looking and saying oh it's impossible
that humans were in the Americas 130,000
years ago so we want mother to look what
a failure of science that is and to
spend all the time instead trying to get
rid of the evidence that doesn't fit the
current paradigm but so fascinating that
just as fortuitous discovery during a
construction site could change the way
people perceive things yes you've got a
wonder how much of that stuff is on how
deep it they have to go to find these
Mastodon bones well so this is a this is
a road cut that's being made so those it
be does it be pretty deep down 10 15
feet down the grader is going through
and flattening them it varies from place
to place depending on on soil deposition
the stratification the stratification of
the soil but what the key the key point
is that what you need to do is go deeper
than 13,000 400 years ago and you need
to do so with dedication and vigor and
and with some kind of funding and at the
moment archaeology doesn't doesn't see
the point of that
if the paper in nature by Tom Demery was
alone if there were nothing else than
that I wouldn't place so much trust in
it but I've spent a lot of time during
the researching of this book with
archaeologists who dig dig deep dig
deeper and what those archaeologists all
confirm is that there have been human
beings in the Americas for tens of
thousands of years and it's not
surprising that that can be pushed back
to 130,000 years ago because part of the
argument about the peopling of the
Americas has to do with a place that we
now call the Bering Straits between
Alaska and Siberia which during the Ice
Age were at times a land bridge they
exposed because of because of lowered
sea levels but migrants who cross that
land bridge from Siberia on many
occasions over periods of tens of
thousands of years would find themselves
confronted then by the North American
ice cap which oddly wasn't at the tip of
Alaska but began further in so there was
living space in a bit of Alaska but you
couldn't get through the ice mountains
these these literally ice mountains - 2
miles deep covering the whole of North
America and preventing access to the
unglaciated parts of America the thing
is that what happened around 13,000 four
hundred years ago there had been a
period of global warming and the ice
sheets began to melt and a corridor
opened up between what's called the
cordelia and ice sheet and the
Laurentide ice sheet the two major ice
keeps in North America and it's thought
that the migration came through that
corridor well the thing is that exactly
the same thing happened between a
hundred and forty thousand years ago and
120 thousand years ago there was an
episode of global warming an ice-free
corridor opened up and the same
opportunity to enter the Americas was
there at that period than it was at the
later period and Tom Demarest point and
mine is that we have to pay much more
attention to that early appeared and
that's really why I've gone ahead and
and written this book is to try to put
before a broad general audience
hopefully in language that makes sense
and an assembly of all the latest
information that casts doubt on the
story we've been told because my
goodness
if archaeology is wrong about the story
of the peopling of the Americas if it's
radically wrong as it now appears to be
then our whole understanding of human
history has to change it's not just the
history of the Americas it's the history
of the entire world it has been an
absolute article of faith amongst
archeologists that civilization began in
the old world and indeed I have a I have
a book in my library called history
begins at Sumer and it's by Samuel Noah
Cramer a very renowned archaeologist and
it's a good book actually but the
argument is that this is where
civilization began in the culture that
we call the Sumerians in Mesopotamia
between the Tigris
the Euphrates rivers and that it began
about 6,000 years ago and that
civilization is entirely an invention of
the old world and has nothing to do with
the new world at all because the new
world was populated so late this is this
has been the this has been the argument
and this is the argument that now
radically and suddenly begins to change
that the Americas this enormous landmass
resource rich bountiful in in every way
south of Minnesota south of the ice cap
vast land areas that are that a
bountiful getting the South Amer Central
America South America the Amazon just
huge areas of land that were very very
offered great potential for human
occupation Dogma has said there were no
humans there now the first bits of
evidence are coming out that says there
were humans there and if that's the case
then we must consider the possibility
that the story of civilization might
have begun in the Americas not in the
old world at all it might be a new world
invention not another invention some of
the more fascinating pieces of evidence
in South America have come out recently
about these channels and pathways that
they've found in the Amazon that could
not have been created any other way but
by humans to creating irrigation humans
creating like it peers like grids like a
city grid definitely the Amazon is a
colossal mystery and it's one of the
subjects that I explore in depth in
America before first of all to give some
basic figures the Amazon basin is huge
the Amazon basin is seven million square
kilometres in area and within it five
and a half million square kilometres
remains almost entirely unstudied by
archeologists and that's the five and a
half million square kilometres that is
still covered by dense rainforest and to
put that into perspective five and a
half million square kilometres is the
size of the entire Indian subcontinent
so it's like saying we've done world
archaeology but we've just ignored India
you know we've done world archaeology
but we just ignored the Amazon it's the
same in the same argument five and a
half million square kilometres the view
was again there was a dogma
there was a preconception human beings
couldn't have flourished in the Amazon
it's a it's not a resource-rich area the
soils are poor it's a difficult area
challenging to get to very far from the
Bering Straits so the view was that
humans hadn't entered the Amazon until
about a thousand years ago and then
gradually little by little that view has
begun to change and it's begun to change
because of the tragic clearances of the
Amazon because the Amazon rainforest is
literally being cut down and turned into
soya bean farms and and cattle ranches
and in that cutting down process has
emerged things that shouldn't be there
at all
for example evidence that large cities
flourished in the Amazon enormous cities
which were larger than the there was a
Spanish explorer who went down the
Amazon River system in 1541 to 1542 he
was the first European to cross the
entire length of South America from west
to east along the Amazon he reported
seeing incredible cities advanced arts
and crafts millions of people a thriving
culture and hundred years later when
other Europeans got into the Amazon they
couldn't find these cities so they said
oh Francisco Orianna that was his name
made it all up it was just a it was just
a fantasy and then in the last decade as
the clearances of the Amazon have
proceeded we've begun to see the traces
of those cities what happened was that
the Spaniards brought smallpox into the
Amazon smallpox devastated the local
population because there was no immunity
to it there was a massive die-off the
cities were deserted within a 50 years
they were completely overgrown by the
jungle and that's why they would not
seen by the explorers who came in a
hundred years later but now the junk is
being cleared those cities are emerging
and we can say that a city like London
which had a population of roughly 50,000
in the 16th century there were cities of
that size all over the Amazon huge
numbers of them and a possible total
population of the Amazon that exceeded
20 million people what yes 20 billion
this is the the latest evidence from the
Amazon and then you ask yourself how did
they do that how did they feed 20
million people in the Amazon because
it's a fact rainforest soils are poor is
one of the reasons these soya bean farms
a really stupid idea because once you
clear the rainforest the land is largely
unfertile and you can't grow stuff
on it for very long so how did they feed
all these people the answer was they
invented a soil and that soil has a name
it's called Terra Preta archaeologists
referred to it as Amazonian dark Earth's
or Amazonian black earth it's a man-made
soil it's thousands of years old it's
full of microbes that are not found in
the joining soil it's based around
biochar and you can take a handful of
eight thousand year old Terra Preta and
you can add it to barren soil and that
soil will instantly become fertile it's
highly sought-after in the Amazon and it
explains how they fed these people there
was science in the Amazon to create this
well this is something that's not
understood it's still not understood by
sole experts to this day as to how that
was done but it's one of many intriguing
evidences pieces of evidence of much
higher development in the Amazon that it
has been given credit for and of a kind
of science in the end Jimmy's got an
image of it up there so this is it Wow
exactly and so was that done by burns
did these controlled burns they did they
one way that it was achieved was was to
do wet burning of middens they would be
they would be burned and smolder they
wouldn't burn fiercely which just
produces charcoal they would they would
burn and smolder and and that but what
is called biochar would result and
that's part of the fertility of the soil
but the mystery is the microbial content
of this soil which is completely
different from the microbes in
neighboring soils and that's remains
unexplained so did they what are the
theories composting some sort of
advanced compost it's some sort of some
sort of advanced composting but again
what has not been explained is the mat
is the microbial content of these soils
so they're there first of all is an
issue of how two things how large
populations get fed in the Amazon and
evidence that there was a culture in the
Amazon that was capable of manipulating
the environment in such a way that it
could support large populations with the
invention of Terra Preta secondly new
evidence previously not recognized the
Amazon is basically a garden the Amazon
is a man-made rainforest there are
certain trees like Brazil nut trees or
the ice cream bean tree which are food
crop
which are very very valuable and they
dominate the the tree regime in in the
Amazon there was what referred to as
hyper dominant species in other words
people living in the Amazon over
thousands of years selected certain
trees which they then cultivated and
grew so the whole thing is not simply a
wild pristine rainforest it's a very
ancient man-made environment and
emerging from that man-made environment
as well as evidence of large cities
large populations and this mysterious
dark earth are huge geometrical
structures and again I go into this at
length in America before because I love
this mystery we have in the UK
structures that are called hinges I
lived in the city of Bath and about 30
miles away there's a beautiful site
called Avebury and another more famous
site called Stonehenge and what a henge
is is a ditch which has been dug deep
and then an embankment has been pushed
up outside the ditch when people first
saw these structures they wondered if
they'd been built for defense but then
it became obvious they hadn't been built
for defense because if you want to
create a moat you put it outside your
embankment not inside your embankment so
a henge is an earthwork which consists
of a deep moat with a large embankment
outside it that it can be circular it
can be square and in the UK and other
parts of Europe it often contains stone
circles megalithic stone circles as well
but the henge itself is entirely an
earthwork what we find in the Amazon are
thousands of henges that are now
beginning to emerge from the cleared
area of the jungle and others that have
been identified for the first time with
lidar lidar technology is being employed
in the Amazon it's non-destructive you
can see what's under the trees what is
lidar light imaging and detective radar
they mounts laser beams down into the
jungle is a whole pattern of them you
need helicopters and they but it doesn't
damage the rainforest and you can strip
away and see what's see what's there if
this isn't too much about diversion let
me give you the example of guatemala
guatemala is a small country if I
remember correctly it's not much more
than a hundred thousand square
kilometers in size it is filled with
intriguing Mayan ruins everybody has
heard of
t-carr what archaeologists didn't know
was that literally within walking
distance of Tikal surrounding that whole
area were more than 60,000 structures
that they hadn't identified and these
have all been identified by lidar in a
country that's just a hundred thousand
kilometres in area so you have to ask
yourself in that five and a half million
square kilometers of the Amazon if lidar
technology could be applied
comprehensively what would we find
beneath there and the evidence already
is extremely tempting and extremely
tantalizing and I'm intrigued by these
huge geometrical figures which involve
primarily circles and squares and they
are classic hinges in the sense that
they are deep ditches surrounded by huge
embankments they're extremely
geometrical for example you can find an
octagon surrounding a square at a place
called jakku saw in the Amazon you can
find a square perfectly enclosing a
circle now that is an exercise called
squaring the circle that are archaea are
our academics have given to the Greeks
they said the Greeks were the first
person people who perform that exercise
but now we find in dated sites in the
Amazon that this was being done in the
Amazon long before the Greeks what are
the dates the earliest dates that have
been found in these sites now are about
three and a half thousand years old
about three and a half thousand years
old but the evidence is that the sites
have been constantly remade and what
intrigues me is what remains in that
five and a half million square
kilometers that has not been
investigated yet we are just I think
looking at the edges of a mystery the
archaeologists involved who are mainly
from Finland and also from Brazil feel
the same they're their estimate is that
there are thousands of these structures
remaining in the jungle and they're open
as to how old they may ultimately prove
to be the investigation needs to be done
but what's fascinating about them is
this very powerful geometry and
astronomy so a number of the sites are
perfectly aligned to true north true
South true East and true West I'm not
talking about magnetic north I'm talking
about true astronomical north to do that
there's only one way to do it and that's
with with astronomy so that tells us
that astronomers were at work in the
Amazon the geometry is
very complex and very precise that tells
us that people with geometrical skills
were at work in the Amazon and thirdly
the scale of the sights of hundreds of
meters gigantic earthworks on the scale
of hundreds of meters tells us that this
was highly organised project that was
undertaken on a very large scale or by
very large numbers of people it's a
wonderful mystery and and it deserves
much further much further attention and
I'm yeah that's jackals are exactly the
squares squaring the circle so you can
see the outside embankment and then
inside it is the square ditch and then
there's another embankment inside that
and a circle and a circle inside that
they've made a road right through that
road yeah you know because because
there's no respect for there's no
respect for the ancient for the ancient
world unfortunately there's another one
wow that's incredible so they found the
the stuff that they found in the Amazon
what imaging technology were they using
to find initially initially it was
entirely found because areas of the
rainforest had been cleared economic
interest said we want to make a cattle
ranch here or we want to make a soya
bean farm here so we're gonna clear the
rainforest in the process of clearing
the rainforest they start discovering
these earthworks that had previously
been completely overgrown by the jungle
then the next step was to say what can
we what could we do to find out more
about this obviously they don't want to
destroy more jungle and luckily we have
a technology which is which is lidar as
I mentioned which uses radar and using
lidar they've been identified able to
identify many more of these sites and
then to get to the sites without
destroying the jungle and to begin
excavations on them and to find that
they go back in the cases of the ones
that have been explored so far at least
three thousand years this is an
intriguing development completely
unexplained in our understanding of the
Amazon and what it suggests is a
heritage of extremely ancient knowledge
you don't wake up one morning and you
know create a perfectly geometrical
square or circular earth work that's
perfectly aligned to true north south
east and west on an enormous scale there
has to be a background to that there's
to be a reason for doing it and the
evidence says none of these sites were
lived in there's no habitation refuse
found
and whatsoever they were they we don't
know what they were used for I make the
case in America before that they're
connected to a system of ideas which is
found all around the world which which
is to do with death and the afterlife
destiny of the soul and I go into the
issue of ayahuasca in in this book
because I first of all I ask is itself
another example of Amazonian science as
you and I and many of the listeners and
viewers know the active ingredient of
ayahuasca is DMT dimethyltryptamine
but dimethyltryptamine is not normally
accessible through the doubt we have to
smoke it or vape it to get that rocket
ship to the other side of reality and
the journey lasts what 1012 minutes not
much more than that and sometimes
sometimes quite a lot less what
ayahuasca does is it makes DMT available
through the gut the reason it's not
available through the gut is because of
an enzyme in the gut called monoamine
oxidase that's which is off DMT on
contact the ayahuasca vine which is one
of the two ingredients of the ayahuasca
brew the other ingredient is leaves that
contain DMT the ayahuasca vine contains
a monoamine oxidase inhibitor which
switches off the enzyme in the gut and
allows the DMT to be accessed orally
which produces a rather different
journey from the smoke to vape DMT trip
is a much longer journey it's four or
five hours it allows you to integrate
and to and to interrelate with the
strange landscapes in which you find
yourself amongst and the entities that
you encounter I'm not making any claims
about the reality status of those
entities but what I am saying and it's a
fact is that people who work with DMT
and ayahuasca do encounter what they
construe to be entities who who
communicate with them intelligently so
somebody in the Amazon out of a hundred
and fifty thousand different species of
plants and trees selected two that are
not psychoactive on their own but when
put together create an extraordinary
visionary brew and ayahuasca means the
vine of the dead and what it's connected
to
in South American religious and
spiritual thinking is what happens to us
when we die and the Takano who are an
Amazonian people who work regularly
forth ayahuasca I mean the Takano
actually will give a teaspoonful of
ayahuasca to a newborn infant they feel
ayahuasca is so important that there is
a hidden realm around us which we are
not normally aware of and we need to be
aware of it and ayahuasca is an
important part of that in their
ayahuasca journeys the Takano shamans
experience visions and they will then
come back to an alert normal
problem-solving state of consciousness
and they will paint and depict their
visions and what's intriguing and I go
into it in the book is that quite a
number of the Takano paintings of the
other world of the afterlife realm of
the entrance to the other world are
geometrical and they look exactly like
the geoglyphs so I'm beginning to wonder
whether these geoglyphs were part of a
system of spiritual ideas concerning
what happens to us after death and what
we need to do in this life to ensure a
beneficial outcome and oddly enough that
same system of ideas is found in the
Mississippi Valley in the Amazon it
involves particularly ayahuasca and the
belief that the ayahuasca journey takes
you to the afterlife realm and a journey
along the Milky Way in the Mississippi
Valley the mound builder sites up and
down the Mississippi Valley particularly
Moundville in Alabama exactly the same
system of religious ideas associated
with geometrical constructions that on
death the soul they're very specific
ascends to the constellation of Orion
transits from the constellation of Orion
to the Milky Way makes a journey along
the Milky Way which they call the path
of souls and encounters challenges and
ordeals where the soul must account for
the life that it has lived then we go to
Egypt and what do we find the same
system of ideas the soul must rise up to
the constellation of Orion there's a
narrow shaft cut through the southern
side of the Great Pyramid of Giza which
targets directly the lowest of the three
stars of Orion's belt widely accepted as
a star shaft or a soul shaft the soul
would rise up through that shaft get to
the constellation of Orion which stands
by the banks of the Milky Way it would
then transit to the
Milky Way which the ancient Egyptians
called the winding waterway and it would
make a journey along the Milky Way where
it would be confronted by challenges and
ordeals very similar idea to the Takano
very similar idea to the Mississippi
Valley as far as we know none of these
cultures were in contact with one
another either we're dealing with a huge
unbelievable extraordinarily detailed
coincidence involving architecture and
ideas or we're looking at the legacy
that was inherited in all of these
different places from a remote common
ancestor and and I believe that that's
what we're looking at what do we think
the people from the ancient Mississippi
Valley though that culture what do we
think they were using if they weren't
using ayahuasca or do we think they
that's what they were using well that's
that's that's an interesting question
whether whether visionary substances are
the only way to get into altered states
of consciousness and and I would say
they are definitely not of course there
are visionary substances which which are
used in Native American vision vision
quests I've I've had the privilege of
peyote ceremony with the Native American
church I've never done that what is a
lot like I loved it actually I thought I
thought it was I thought it was amazing
it wait it doesn't overpower you in the
way that DMT or ayahuasca does it's it's
it's much gentler it's much more you
feel much more integrated and connected
with with with nature your thought
processes are quite quite clear it felt
it felt just like a very beautiful and
healing experience and I love the
ceremony that I mean I'm inside a teepee
with with 30 or 40 other people and
they're there there are specific roles
that are assigned to those different
individuals one will keep the door and
other will be responsible for the fire
which is a work of art in itself just
gazing into that fire and the glowing
the glowing embers is enough to induce
an altered state of consciousness on its
own
incredible drumming which which drives
your state of consciousness into a kind
of peak peak experience this is a
technology for accessing other levels of
experience and other levels of reality
and it's clear that the Native Americans
had a number of advanced technologies in
this area the Sun Dance doesn't use a
substance but it uses austerity it uses
pain to drive an altered state of
consciousness the objective in every
case seems to be let's just for a while
get our cell
out of the narrow rigid frame of the
alert problem-solving state of
consciousness we all need that it's
incredibly useful hunter-gatherers need
it just as much as people in in cities
need it but it's not the only state of
consciousness available to human beings
and maybe that's one of the big mistakes
that we're making in our culture
and was not made in in shamanistic
societies that dad is a really
interesting breakdown that maybe that is
one of the big mistakes we're making in
our culture when people point to the
problems that we have in this country
one of the problems we have is our
inability to connect with each other
yeah or to recognize that it we're all
sharing the space and time together
instead wanting to uphold our own
religious or ideological ideas as being
the only one way to get going yeah the
only one way to get through and one of
the things that I found these
psychedelic experiences it really makes
ideologies seem if not preposterous at
the very least insignificant in
comparison to human experiences
absolutely the experience of camaraderie
and friendship and and love it you
realize like oh this is what's important
this is what is really about not not
enforcing your ideas or pushing them on
other people and forcing people to
behave the way you behave they instead
love and think about religious ideas
which caused so much division so much
chaos so much hatred so much fear so
much suspicion in the world today is it
really what we want to do as human
beings simply to accept a package of
ideas that were believed in by our
ancestors to accept them whole without
question as absolute fact which we
regard as such authoritative fact that
in some cases we're willing to be deeply
unpleasant to people who hold different
views or perhaps even kill them we've
had this you know this recent event in
in in in Sri Lanka a primarily a
religiously motivated terrorist event it
happens it happens all over the world
people feel so convinced that the
inherited package of ideas that they had
nothing to do with creating and that
they have never questioned they're so
convinced that those ideas are right
that in extreme cases they're actually
prepared to kill other human beings who
hold different ideas they
they so insecure in their own in their
own beliefs that that they're prepared
to go to that level of actually
murdering another human being who holds
they're so threatened by the other
beliefs that other human beings hold so
it's an abnegation of our responsibility
as human beings we should be questioning
things we should not be accepting
packages of ideas intact fully formed
and using them to drive the way we
behave towards one another that was part
of the human story but we need to move
on from that and it's a very dangerous
situation in a very complex modern world
with billions of human beings on the
planet to have these kind of energies
been generated where certain groups of
people are saying we are absolutely
right and you are absolutely wrong we
are superior you are inferior this is a
very very dangerous path that we're that
we on and it needs to be changed
personally I know this is not a comment
that will go down well with many people
but I am strongly opposed to nationalism
I don't I don't see any virtue in
nationalism it is an accident of birth
which nation you were born in it was
nothing that you did for your own merit
you didn't earn that you were born by
accident in in a particular nation why
should we automatically feel that other
people who were born by accident in that
particular nation have something special
in common with us and that we together
are a group who are much more important
than other groups of people I've been
privileged to spend my life traveling
around the world living with communities
all over over the world and one thing
that really comes across to me strongly
it's it should be a cliche and yet it's
not is that we are all one family that
humans are intimately interconnected all
around the world that you can go to the
remotest area of the Amazon jungle and
find the same hopes the same fears the
same dreams that we have in
industrialized cities shared by the
hunter-gatherers in the in the middle of
the Amazon so our similarities as human
beings and what we share in common at
the emotional level and the level of
love and at the level of heart are far
more important than our differences that
are defined by the nation or the
political group in which we in which we
grew up in and when I when I say I'm
against nationalism I need also to make
clear that does not mean and I hope I'm
not taken out of context by others who
are listening to this that does not me
I'm in favor of world government I
detest governments that's another thing
we need to grow out of
we don't need governments anymore if we
have them they should have a very
minimal role in our society I think it's
possible for the human race to relate as
one family without leaders and
governments who are exploiting the worst
aspects of our character the lowest
common denominator of our society
deliberately encouraging fears and
hatreds and suspicions what responsible
leaders should be doing is encouraging
love and unity and their failure to do
that in my view disqualifies them from
the leadership role entirely and that's
why I've often said I would not I would
like to see a situation in which no head
of state can be appointed to that
position unless he or she has first had
12 sessions of ayahuasca that would be
the condition don't even bother applying
for the job
you haven't done this and we have to be
there where you have it and we have to
be we want to see that you're drinking
every drop and we want an experienced
shaman present who's really gonna guide
you through the through the journey and
I suspect that that would be a
transformative experience for many of
our political class and that they would
start to question why they do what they
do why they exploit fears in order to
magnify their own position they'd start
to question that and to wonder about a
different destiny for Humanity but
that's a dream I guess it's not gonna
happen it's very very very well said and
I couldn't agree more my hope is that at
what you were saying and what we were
discussing earlier about how the
Internet is sort of eroded our faith in
many institutions as being the only or
the primary source of knowledge that I
hope that that takes place globally in
terms of the way we view government yeah
and that we do and that your idea of
like I love what America stands for and
what America stands for is kind of a
nation that's where people go to you
know this is one of the more insidious
problems with this idea of building
walls and keeping people out making it
incredibly difficult to get here the
reason why I'm here is because it was
pretty easy to get here yeah that's why
I'm here that's not the essence of
America a free open society to come here
and do better yes that's the whole idea
behind it and
I would hope that this idea of being
able to just if you want to do matter
you can anywhere in the world yeah this
could eventually spread out yes this is
my hope I believe it can spread out and
and you know I see many signs of hope in
in in America America has become a big
part of my life not just because I wrote
this book but because I have children
who are now living in America I have a
son and daughter-in-law who live in LA I
have another son and daughter-in-law who
live in Boston America I'm British but
America has become a very central part
of my life and it's a fascinating an
amazing country and it's been my
privilege to travel thousands of miles
across America across many many many
different states and I I love this
country it's a it's a it's an amazing
place only in America could we see
happening what has happened with
cannabis you know the the fact that at a
at a local level individuals have got
together mobilized petitions organized
votes and changed the law changed the
law define literally stuck a finger up
at central government and said [ __ ] off
this is none of your business what I do
with my consciousness in the inner
sanctum of my own life is not the
business of the state that's a very
American feeling it's it's something
that you don't find often in other
countries where the state is granted
much more power and much more authority
than it perhaps should be Americans are
naturally questioning of government
authority and that has that as what has
led to the legalization increasing
legalization of cannabis which is going
to change the world in lots of ways but
then ironically at the same time see the
thing about democracies is that in order
to get things done in a democracy you
need to persuade people of your point of
view so information becomes very
important in in democracies and the
information can be abused people can be
mislead with information they can be
told that what they're receiving is the
truth whereas in fact it's not the truth
and you can end up with a kind of
dictatorship that the people have given
their assent to on the basis of false
information and frankly I'd rather have
a real dictatorship which is which is
out in the open and
clear rather than one that has been
subtly manipulated into position through
manipulating the the views of the of the
voters but I am and remain enormous ly
encouraged by America it may seem like a
trivial issue but the fact that state by
state
cannabis is being legalized and that is
resulting from a grassroots movement
that this enormous change has been made
it's ironic it's strange that at the
federal level even though what eight
states now totally legal for
recreational 23 24 states legal for for
medical use that at the federal level
it's still a Schedule one control
control drug this is a huge state of
dissonance that exists in America is
going to have to put it right what it
says to me is that people can change
things people can get together at the
local level and they can make a better
world because there's no doubt that the
cannabis laws were vicious and wrong and
cruel and evil and ruined people's lives
for decades and it's people who've
changed that it's not government this
change that it's the people at the
grassroots level America is a country
where that can happen and I remain
encouraged about about the role of the
American people while often in despair
about the role of the American state
yeah I'm encouraged as well and you know
what's interesting Ben and Jerry
released something yesterday which is
really are on 4/20 I should say which
was talking about the drug laws in this
country and and talking about how many
it's really really opening this the the
idea of like how unjust these laws were
and how many of these laws targeted
people of color and how many people who
are white people have profited off of
this and how many people are still in
jail for crimes that they committed you
know air-quote crimes yeah that are no
longer crime that are no longer crimes
yeah and this is ridiculous and these
these records should be expunged they
should because I see that California has
made some steps in that direction
there's been some expunging of records
well we can only hope that also what
what opens up next is psilocybin is now
going to be on the ballot absolutely and
when that opens up I mean what you
really think marijuana is a gateway drug
well guess what it is
if psilocybin gets in yes because
psilocybin can legitimately change the
world
yes account it really I mean I think
marijuana can change the world and I
really
you think that cannabis is changing
people's perceptions and making people
more calm and friendly and yeah and even
the what they talk about with paranoia I
welcome that and the reason why I
welcome that is I think people are
entirely too cocky yeah the life we live
is bizarre as you could ever imagine
that book and we're just accustomed to
it because it's our day to day it for
granted yeah
marijuana removes those blinders and it
really makes you understand that this is
a strange strange life and these a lot
of these pitfalls and problems that we
have in our society or due to fear and
they're due to the ignorance and they're
due to this this lack of connection with
each other and cannabis and many of
these other psychedelic drugs they
encourage this connection with each
other I think what we need it's
certainly what we need and and and it's
an aberration in human culture that
we've created a society that demonized
these substances and that made them
illegal it's a relatively recent thing
it's really just the last the last
hundred years it's a it's a tiny part of
the human story and yet we were so
arrogant as a society that we could set
aside thousands of years of human
tradition and experience and wisdom
working with the plant medicines we just
set it aside turn them into criminal
substances and say we know everything
what a what a huge and stupid mistake
that is on cannabis as a quote-unquote
gateway drug it absolutely is in this
sense that the legalization of cannabis
is going to open the doors to as you say
to the legalization of psychedelics
because what's happening is that the
population is completely waking up to
the fact that they have been bullshitted
and lied to about cannabis for the best
part of a century
and once that dawns on people the the
realization at a direct personal level
here's this herb I love I have been lied
to systematically misinformed by central
government about this about this herb
that leads to questioning of everything
that central government does and so in
that sense it is a gateway to a
questioning society the psychedelics are
different in that in that psilocybin
actually does lead you to question stuff
it leads you to really
ask questions about about everything
about your role in the world about you
as a person about how you relate to
other people and about the whole system
on this planet and that the beautiful
gorgeous planet that we that we have and
what we're doing to it that that also
enters enters awareness so it arose
confidence and authority and it also
roads confidence and authority that
doesn't have experiences that you've
experienced actually that's the part of
the problem is that these people that
are holding people back from these
psychedelic experiences they've never
had them they've never they don't even
know what they're rallying they're
coming to it from a place of fear and
Prejudice they're simply accepting stuff
that they've been told without really
thinking it through and and examining it
and again it's a failure of what human
beings should should be doing we have to
get we have to get rid of this fear and
ironically it's bad for them as well so
bad for the people that are actually
encouraging this these laws to be
enforced yes it's bad for the is bad for
the whole of the whole of society
because it is healthy for a for a
society where adults become
self-realized individuals where they
make their own responsible choices about
their own lives where they don't say oh
government must make this choice for me
that's the next step for Humanity we
start we need to start becoming our own
leaders and making our own choices and
that is that is what's being revealed
now that we're getting to the skull
beneath the smile of the war on drugs
we're realizing that it's part of a big
program of lying that has been about
keeping people's minds closed down not
wanting free thinking I've made this
point several times but our society is
not against altered states of
consciousness as such our society will
allow Big Pharma to make billions of
dollars with drugs that alter
consciousness like surak's hat and
Prozac antidepressants which in my
opinion having had some experience of
them are amongst the most horrible drugs
on the planet
they are very harmful very dangerous
drugs but they're completely legal and
they're encouraged with our system
likewise alcohol very dangerous drug
causes fights causes drunk driving
accidents leads to cirrhosis of the
liver completely legal and open our
society is not against altered states of
consciousness as such it's against
particular kinds of altered states of
consciousness but lead to questioning of
the existing control
that's what's that's what's going on
here here here well said and as you know
I have my own story with with with
cannabis yeah well you and I had a
moment we had a moment which was which
was quite a life-changing moment for me
because if I may just rehearse a little
bit of this for the audience in 2011 I
had a series of ayahuasca sessions in
which it was shown to me that I was
using cannabis completely wrong that it
had become a dominant force in my life
that it was making me you're speaking
about paranoia and I agree with your
paranoia is a useful thing if only to
overcome it that it was making me
paranoid that it was making me
suspicious that I approached everybody
around me in a state of suspicion and I
was shown this by ayahuasca and given a
very strong message you need to quit
cannabis what I didn't realize at the
time is that the problem was not
cannabis the problem was me that I
needed to fix those aspects of myself
before I could have a proper
relationship with cannabis so after that
ayahuasca session having smoked cannabis
for decades literally 16 hours a day
seven days a week I quit I quit for
three years and then I'm on your show
and we're sitting we're sitting opposite
one another as we are now and you asked
me a question
are you still off the cannabis and that
and I say well I'm thinking of dipping
my toes back in the water at which point
you produce a joint and we smoked it
together first of all after three years
your tolerance is way down on cannabis
so I got really stoned I did listen to
that interview back and somehow I held
it together
oh you held it together brilliantly you
opened up and there was like a wave of
information came pouring out of you yeah
it was wonderful it was a liberation for
me and what it said to me is it's time
to go back to cannabis but perhaps in a
different way it doesn't it I need a
different relationship with this amazing
medicine and and if I can forge that if
I can make that different relationship
happen then it can be a constructive and
positive part of my life and I can say
definitely that that has been the case
and that's excellent and so it's all
thanks to you Joe I probably would still
be off cannabis if it hadn't been for
that joint well I think people can
develop these patterns of behavior that
are destructive
with anything whether it's with alcohol
or cannabis or you know yes sex or
anything people get to get in ruts yeah
you know it doesn't mean that the
cannabis is best means that you are on a
bad mental path yes you know exactly and
I mean I'm not encouraging it for
everybody because some people genuinely
biologically doesn't jive with them yeah
yeah yeah the fundamental thing is we as
I thought human beings need to take
responsibility for our own lives and our
own decisions yeah and we need not hand
that responsibility over to governmental
institutions especially when it concerns
something as intimate and personal as
our consciousness and my view is the
ancient world had the right attitude to
this kind of thing yeah and the modern
world does not and that we can sit down
and learn a lot from the ancient world a
lot of people ask me you know Hancock
you've been arguing that there's a loss
there's been a lost civilization in the
in the human story but what what sort of
civilization do you think it was well
one of the things I think is it was a
civilization that used psychedelics I
think it was a civilization that emerged
from shamanism but did not stay at the
hunter-gatherer stage but that took the
essence of shamanism and integrated it
into a very different kind of
civilization from our own which pursued
things in different ways a lot of
archaeologists have said to me but we
don't find any plastic bottles from the
Ice Age that means there was no advanced
civilization during the Ice Age well
hang on
maybe an advanced civilization might
have decided never to get involved in
plastic in the first place maybe there
would have been a clear choice not to
make plastic maybe they did things in
completely different ways maybe they
cultivated powers of the human mind that
we dismiss and regard as completely
completely unimportant you know whoo
whoo yeah this is the thoughts about
Egypt correct it's about about Egypt and
and and about other things I mean the
specific example I give is above the
King's Chamber in the Great Pyramid are
five further chambers and these chambers
are roofed and floored with granite
beams that weigh about 70 tons each and
there are hundreds of them and these
70-ton granite beams which to put in
context
Sunbeam is equivalent in weight to 35
large SUVs these 70-ton granite beams
have been elevated to a height of more
than 350 feet above the ground and
carefully and precisely placed in
position it is very hard for
archaeologists to explain how that was
done using purely leverage and
mechanical advantage you can say or
perhaps they built a ramp and and and
hold the stones up the ramp but then you
have to confront basic laws of physics
you can't haul a stone weighing tens of
tons up a slope that exceeds ten degrees
then you start doing the calculation how
long a ramp do I need with a 10 degree
slope to get to 350 feet above the
ground and the answer is you need a
[ __ ] long ramp which should still be
there because not it couldn't have been
a sand ramp I would have collapsed under
the weight of those stones it had to be
as massive as the pyramid itself so this
begins to seem like an absurd idea the
the idea that is foisted on us by
archaeology maybe the idea that they
regard as absurd namely that psychic
powers were cultivated by ancient
civilizations that they could use powers
of the human mind that we have allowed
to lapse maybe that idea deserves
further consideration we have gone down
a path of leverage and mechanical
advantage we're used to relying on
machines but we hear anecdotal reports
of people who have telekinetic powers
who can move things with their minds of
people who have telepathic powers and
our automatic reaction is to just
dismiss all of that because science says
it's impossible because science regards
consciousness as as local to the brain
and doesn't see how it can exert itself
outside of that but maybe we should open
up to those possibilities that we're
dealing with a very different kind of
culture that used techniques that we
have allowed to lapse and maybe we could
wake those techniques up again maybe the
ability of human beings to do almost
superhuman things is resident within all
of us but sleeping well it's pure
speculation that they use some sort of a
telekinetic power but it's pure
speculation but it's absolute that they
did something that we don't understand
if you think about the distance between
us and the construction just a mod
accepted construction dates of the Great
Pyramid it's more than five thousand
years ago we're close to five thousand
years ago right parents supposed to be
about four thousand five hundred years
old yeah that's really old yeah you'd
think that someone back then could do
something that would perplex us today
yeah with modern machinery yeah and that
somehow or another they figure this out
it's almost like what they had done was
leave behind something that was so
stupendous so monstrously impressive
that it would transcend time yeah and
that you would have to look at it even
thousands and thousands of years later
and say hey like this this defies
conventional explanation this is not a
simple and I've seen some of the
conventional explanations of the
construction of the pyramid and they
conveniently neglect those chambers
above the King's Chamber they do they
conveniently neglect a lot of those
massive stones yeah and it's because
it's it's one of those things you just
go oh I don't know what is this Jamie
they're the they're the gems above the
above the King's chambers and each one
of those floors is is consists of a row
of 70-ton granite blocks that have been
raised 350 feet above the ground and not
only that but brought from Aswan in the
south of Egypt 500 kilometers south of
the south of the Great Pyramid so if
there's any time in history we could go
in a time machine and go back and
observe would that be the time I am just
completely fascinated by the Ice Age and
I say at the moment have you had one
shot to go back and see what it was like
in some place you wouldn't go to the
construction of the Great Pyramids I
think right now where I'd go is twelve
thousand eight hundred years ago in the
beginning of the Younger Dryas just to
see because I think that's where the
whole human story changes I think that's
where we change tracks from one path to
another path and following those
cataclysmic events of the Younger Dryas
between twelve thousand eight hundred
and eleven thousand six hundred years
ago following those the signs of
civilization that we see emerging are
not the beginnings of civilization
they're a restart of civilization that
had existed before the Cataclysm and for
that reason I would I would like to be
present during that cataclysmic event if
only to satisfy my
self that it was indeed a comet you see
the the one thing there's no dispute
about anymore is that the Younger Dryas
was a cataclysm you can't argue about
that the the the megafauna that that
died off the disruption of human
activity that takes place at that time
the huge climate changes this was a
cataclysm by any standards where the
argument still goes on is what caused
the what caused the Cataclysm I vote
strongly for comet multiple fragments of
a comet hitting the North American ice
cap and hitting Greenland as well but
there are other researchers in the field
like my colleague Robert Schoch who
thinks that the Sun is more involved
this is healthy this is very very
healthy that there should we should be
approaching this problem from many
different perspectives and trying to
figure out what the [ __ ] caused this
extraordinary event that occurs at a
pivotal moment in the human story the
end of the Stone Age the beginning of
the Mesolithic the end of the Ice Age
the beginning of the current age of the
earth and suddenly we see these signs of
civilization appearing and in places
like gobekli tepe those signs already
include highly sophisticated knowledge
and that's why I feel we really need to
investigate the Amazon there are there
are three places in the world which are
really lacking in the investigation
right now one of them is the Amazon five
and a half million square kilometres
very little archaeology done another is
the Sahara Desert the Sahara Desert
tough place to work I can understand why
there's little archaeology done there
but the Sahara Desert was Green during
the Ice Age it had a completely
different climate regime we should
consider the possibility that missing
parts of the human story are there and
then under the continental shelves
because sea level rose 400 feet these
are three domains that archaeology has
largely not investigated and and it has
largely not done so they say well why
would we spend the money on marine
archaeology it's much better to spend it
on looking for shipwrecks rather than
looking for signs of a lost civilization
because we archaeologists know there was
no lost civilization so that's the
argument for the resources there and the
same the same with the Amazon and the
same with the with with the Sahara
Desert places in the very places in the
world that those amongst us who are
charged with the responsibility of
interpreting the past have not looked at
are the very prices we
should be looking at I had a thought
once while I was under the influence and
it was a thought that one day
computational powers will reach a point
where they will be able to take into
consideration all of the objects on
earth and what we know about the history
and vividly recreate the past through
through computation to the point where
you could actually know who did what
when people did things and that I mean I
don't even know if this would be
physically today certainly not be
possible but with the exponential
increase in computational power and
technology and innovation that one day
will reach a point where you'll be able
to watch you'll be able to see what
happened yeah and they'll be able to
recreate what happened exactly
and that this would be something that
would be I mean it's impossible for us
to imagine that someone would be able to
do that right now yeah but that one day
with technology as it gets more and more
advanced and we will reach some sort of
a some innovation or some sort of an
invention that will allow us to go back
and see literally see what what happened
how things were done technologies is
changing our whole understanding of the
past and what your envisaging is
perfectly possible we will we will come
to a time if 100 years 500 perhaps less
if if we don't you know first destroy
ourselves entirely as a civilization we
will come to a time where our cleverness
and our techniques will allow a much
wider opening up of the past than has
presently happened but it is already
happening one of the areas of science
that I go into in America before is
genetics and and DNA this is an area of
science that was not much informing
archeology until about the 1990s but
since the 2000s has become very
important in archeology because the
technology has been developed where
ancient DNA can be extracted and tested
and you can actually genotype an entire
individual from DNA that maybe fifteen
twenty thousand twenty thousand years
old
and this new technology of genome
sequencing and DNA is another factor
that is raising huge question marks over
the past of the Americas and one of the
issues I go into in this book is the
presence in the Amazon rainforest of a
very specific clearly identifiable
pattern of DNA which is only found in
one other place in the world and that is
in Australasia in Papua New Guinea and
amongst Australian Aborigines it's
Australasian DNA now South American not
only in South America but in the depths
of the Amazon rainforest amongst tribes
who have only been contacted in the last
20 or 30 years and furthermore although
skeletal remains are rare it has been
found in ancient skeletal remains that
are close to 11,000 years old in the
Amazon so that tells us that this DNA
signal has been in the Amazon for at
least 11,000 years the geneticists think
that it came to the Amazon during the
last ice age and this raises a huge
mystery because the peopling of the
Americas is supposed to have occurred
from Siberia across the Bering Straits
down through that ice-free corridor into
North America down through North America
into South America into Central America
and finally into South America if that
was the whole story then we would find
this DNA signal in North America and in
Central America we would not find it
only in the Amazon when I talked to some
of the leading geneticists about this
but specifically SK professor SK Willis
live at the University of Copenhagen
there's been the lead author in a number
of major studies of ancient DNA and I
asked him what do you make of this
Australasian DNA in in the Amazon and
and he said honestly we don't have a
proper explanation for it at the moment
but what he did say is that the most
parsimonious explanation he used that
specific word the most parsimonious
explanation is that a group of people
during the Ice Age crossed the Pacific
Ocean and settled up and ended up in
South America and settled in the Amazon
and brought their DNA with them
that would account perfectly for the DNA
data and when a scientist says the most
parsimonious explanation what that
scientist is saying is he likes that
explanation then is a simple direct
clear explanation of the DNA mystery but
then he added however it doesn't make
practical sense and I asked him well why
doesn't it make practical sense and he
said because the archaeologists tell me
that no human population was capable of
crossing the Pacific Ocean during the
Ice Age at which point it was natural
for me to say do you really trust the
archaeologists and he said well in
science we do trust the work of other
scientists we don't really question it
we don't really investigate it that's
their side of the their side of the
business and and my view is that that is
rather than rather than accept rather
than taking this weird anomalous
Australasia and DNA signal in the in the
in the heart of the Amazon as something
to be explained away and as something to
be the for it to be denied that it could
be connected to a voyage across the
Pacific Ocean maybe it's the first
compelling evidence that voyages were
taking a place across the Pacific Ocean
during the Ice Age and maybe we should
be opening up that whole issue for
exploration and again I think I lost a
lost civilization is the best answer and
that near the end of the Ice Age when
when the Younger Dryas Cataclysm unfolds
it's not an overnight thing it's very
bad twelve thousand eight hundred years
ago
there's about 1200 years of horror I
don't think this civilization went down
in a single day and night I think there
were survivors
I think bits of it were left I think
their project was to restart
civilization and I suggest very strongly
that where they tried to mount that
project was amongst the hunter-gatherers
who coexisted in the world with them at
that time we ourselves are an advanced
civilization at least that's what we
call ourselves and we coexist in the
world with hunter-gatherers it's not an
odd idea that an advanced civilization
that hunter-gatherers should coexist and
there is separation between us and the
Amazonian hunter-gatherers there are
tribes in the Amazon that are
uncontacted and that we that we don't
know even exist
if a catastrophe on the level of the
Younger Dryas were to occur today I
don't think that our civilization would
make it through
we are the spoilt children of the earth
we are just used to having everything
laid on you know the supermarket shelves
are groaning with with food we can get
food delivered to our homes we have
roofs over our head we have shelters we
have clothes everything is taken for
granted
I guess you're an exception but very few
people in modern Western culture know
how to survive they don't have survival
skills they don't know how to hunt they
don't know how to gather they don't know
how to grow crops because they've handed
that responsibility over to others we
live in a society that's highly
segmented and specialized and different
people specialize in different things
but nobody has the vast general survival
skill that a hunter-gatherer has so in a
global Cataclysm actually at first
counter-intuitively
the people who would survive it would be
the hunter-gatherers and an advanced
civilization would be smart if there
were survivors to seek refuge amongst
hunter-gatherers to make that the place
where they might try to start restart
their civilization and that's why I
think that this Australasian DNA signal
in the Amazon may be part of the
evidence for a sort of outreach effort
that was being made by a lost
civilization seeing the disaster coming
down on it and realizing that something
needed to be done well it's fascinating
to me that the geneticists would rely on
the archaeologists being that the
geneticists have the actual DNA they can
examine where the archaeologists are
piecing things together yeah tiny bits
of information over the entire landscape
and then you consider how much
information they don't have access to
that's in the ground exactly I
I strongly resist the idea that
archaeology is a science I I don't think
it should be described as a science what
do you think it should be described it's
more like a kind of philosophy it's it's
it's a it's an attempt to interpret the
past based on rather flimsy and limited
evidence and what you find in that
interpretation is that the
preconceptions of the individuals
involved are being imposed upon the
evidence which then turns out to support
their preconceptions and that's not a
scientific way of doing things assigned
way of doing things is testing testing
hypotheses and false seeking to falsify
them and seeing if they if they if they
work out so the problem is drawing these
conclusions and being too rigid with
these conclusions that's on the further
evidence that's that's my view yeah that
archaeology has been has been much too
rigid and and and that there's a there's
a climate of fear in archeology I don't
mean to pick particularly on
archaeologists here I think this is
generally true across other disciplines
as well these days academics are driven
by the need to publish research papers
that's what they build their careers on
if they can get a paper on their bit of
research published in nature or the
Proceedings of the National Academy of
Sciences etc that's good for their
careers but then you confront the
gatekeepers in those publications who
regard any archaeological idea that is
not part of the mainstream accepted
consensus with great suspicion and are
most most reluctant to to you know to
publish to publish that information now
what is the mainstream when
archaeologists talk about seafaring
humans when what what do they date that
- well there's the big raisins
yes the great seafaring adventure that
is accepted by archaeology is called the
Polynesian expansion and it's a
remarkable story and that occurs roughly
3,000 to 3,500 years ago and those
Polynesians were amazing ocean
navigators they could they could cross
distances of thousands of kilometres
with pinpoint accuracy I mean it's not
an accident that the Polynesians found
Easter Island fighting Easter Island is
a really challenging project Easter
Island is 2,000 miles from the coast of
South America it's 2,000 miles from the
nearest other Island which is Tahiti
it's just a little speck in the middle
of the ocean but the Polynesians found
it and settled there and appear to have
brought a reproductively viable
population there and appear to have made
voyages back and forth but that was
3,000 to 3,500 years ago that was not
12,000 800 years ago and this is this is
where archaeology's adamant position
that ocean voyages was begun by the
Polynesians and that there was no
your ocean voyages before that I think
needs to be strongly questioned and it
needs to be strongly questioned in the
light of this DNA evidence from the
Amazon rather than rejecting the
evidence and temp should be made to
consider what that might mean well it's
interesting because we know that the
Egyptians had boats yeah and so what I
mean if there were boats 4,500 years ago
why do we think that they didn't try
them out in the ocean that doesn't make
any sense especially if there existed a
thousand years prior which is also
possible
archaeologists wouldn't argue that the
Egyptians had boats but but that is that
is still within the the framework of
accepted history it's the notion of a
global navigating culture in the Ice Age
that archaeologists can't swallow it's a
subject that I've kept on coming up
against over a number of years I think
the best evidence for it is ancient maps
which show the world as it looked during
the last ice age I first explored this
in fingerprints of the gods and I've
touched on the mystery again and I
haven't an appendix on the subject in in
in this book because I think these are
very important we're talking about maps
that were drawn roughly between the
1300s and the 1700s in other words in
relatively recent history however these
maps were largely based on much older
source maps which they copied and we can
say that for sure because one of the
famous maps is the piri Reis map which
was created by a Turkish Admiral called
piri Reis in the year 1513 actually only
a corner of his map has survived it was
originally a world map we now just have
a bit that shows the east coast of South
America and North America and the west
coast of Africa piri Reis writes in that
map that it is in his own handwriting
that he based it on more than 100 older
source maps some of which had come from
the Library of Alexandria in other words
that maps had been when the Library of
Alexandria had been destroyed in the 4th
century idea whenever it was some of its
contents had been rescued and brought to
Constantinople which became the Turkish
capital and piri Reis had access to
those maps and he incorporated
information from those maps on his maps
as well as incorporating more recent
navigational information and this is one
of a whole category of maps which are
extremely hard to explain
all of them based on all their source
maps now lost all of them incorporating
extremely precise relative longitudes
and latitudes latitude is not that
difficult to technological feat but
longitude is a difficult technological
feat longitude involves a chronometer it
involves knowing the time at the place
you began your voyage and the local and
local noon as well and calculating the
difference between them you need a
chronometer that will keep accurate time
at sea with the motions of a ship and
it's just a plain fact that our
civilization did not invent such a
chronometer until the late 18th century
before that we didn't know what
longitude were we were at and ships were
constantly sailing unexpectedly into
coastlines that they thought were
hundreds of miles further away so the
discovery of the technique to do
longitude was a major civilizational
advance its presence in maps based on
much older source maps that actually
showed the world as it looks during the
last ice age suggests that somebody
during the last ice age was mapping the
world and had mastered the technique of
calculating longitude classic example of
these maps and I make a point of this is
what's called the Pinkerton world map
which was drawn in the year 1818 and it
was based on the latest navigational
information at that time I reproduced
that map in the in the book what's
missing from the map entirely missing is
Antarctica there's just a hole at the
bottom of the world there's nothing
there and the reason there reason
there's nothing there there's another
there's another Pinkerton map that that
shows that the the reason that you need
to find one that's centered on
Antarctica the reason the reason that
Antarctica is not there is that our
civilization hadn't discovered
Antarctica in 1818 so they couldn't
authentically put it on a map in 1818
actually we discovered it in 1819 and
that's when it starts appearing on
modern maps the problem is that
Antarctica repeat appears repeatedly on
these much older maps and it appears in
the right place and a bit bigger than it
is today but very much as it looked
during the last ice age
so what all of this suggests to me is
that the world was mapped and explored
by a global seafaring culture with a
level of technology that was at least
equivalent to ours at the end of the
18th century during the Ice Age wasn't
there also a map of Greenland that
showed it underneath the ice yes there
are and and and and another intriguing
thing I met I mentioned the piri Reis
map just now shown on the piri Reis map
lying off the east coast of North
America is a large island with a row of
megaliths like a road of megaliths
running up the middle of it that Island
is in the exact place of the Grand
Bahama banks and yeah it is but can I
point it out to you because we're sure
okay that's great that you can bring
this up Jamie that's amazing so this
island is sitting there off the
southeast coast of North America look at
the way these two draw things back then
too and and what you see running down
the middle of it is this road like
feature of megaliths yes I see right
there yeah mm-hmm thing is there was a
long period of my life when I I did a
lot of scuba diving and I was looking at
at underwater structures and one of the
sites had tithed on was the Bimini Road
which is in the Grand Bahama banks mhm
and the Bimini Road is exactly where
that island is and that here's the issue
I don't care whether the Bimini Road is
natural or man-made for me the mystery
is that it is shown above water on that
map and the last time it was above water
was thousands and thousands of years ago
so for me this is all evidence that we
shouldn't dismiss the possibility that
our ancestors had achieved a level of
technology where they could explore and
map the world's oceans we shouldn't
dismiss that we don't know what those
stones are or how they were created but
boy do they look artifacts Yonaguni and
you're looking at now but the back to
that image Jimmy did the last image that
we were just looking at look at I mean
that looks so man-made and and you can
see it is rather like the the pattern
that's shown on the on the island in the
in the map how deep is that today oh
it's not very deep it's about 20 feet
there's but we think that that was above
water
obviously was definitely above water
during the last ice age when it when it
finally went underwater may have been as
late as eight or nine thousand years is
there anything else compelling that's in
the immediate area that seems to
indicate that there was some sort of a
man-made structure well nobody's looked
for it and the whole effort of
archeology has been to dismiss the
significance of the Bimini Road how
would they dismiss that well they say
it's just a mean they say it's totally
natural come back to that image again
this is the odd you go back to that
image that we just saw yeah yeah sure
somebody who spent a lot of time diving
on the Bimini Road I can tell you I
absolutely do not think it's natural I
think it's a man-made structure but the
argument is that it's a kind of beach
rock that forms in these blocky
formations as beach rock does form in
Bakke formation but here I believe that
the beach rock has been used as a
construction material but I repeat the
key issue is not whether the Bimini Road
is man-made or not and the key issue is
that it features on a map above water
and that is a dating project that tells
us that somebody was mapping that bit of
the world when it was above water and go
back that takes us back a very long a
long way into the past though the one
that you just pulled up you know look at
that one it's a stunning place it's
animate this amazing site it's just like
the odds of that being in that order
with those uniformly sized rocks for how
long is that Oh hundreds of feet it's a
huge it's actually shaped like a letter
J it's a giant underwater structure it's
really really an enormous thing and very
very beautiful to dive on and there's
lots of very gentle sweet nurse sharks
down there that you can play with this
so that looks much more like random
that's more random a bit a bit bit of it
do look more random mmm and bits of it
look highly constructed I would not I
would not seek to to claim that the
Bimini Road is absolutely man-made mine
claim about the Bimini Road is it's
really [ __ ] weird that it appears on
a map above water yeah a map that was
drawn in 1513 based on older source map
now when they found that ancient Greek
computer thing and what is our mechanism
yes yeah again that testifies to a lost
navigational skill that we have not
taken account of it's incredibly complex
and it took a long time for them
figure out what that even is yeah what
do they think that is now it tracks the
movements of the planets it's a it's a
navigational device it's it's a geared
cogged system that allows you to track
the passage of time and figure out where
you are it's it's some kind of
navigational device it's not fully
understood in how old is that I think
that goes back to Greek times I'm
guessing here because Greek times are
not of great interest to me but I'm
thinking around about 500 BC so at least
2,000 years old 2,000 plus and we know
that there had to be more than one of
these things yes
you can't you can't have something like
that without without a vast effort
behind it
human beings were working on creating
this geared and cogged machinery that
that reflected the powers that are
recreation so that's a recreation one of
those don't look so you buy that dude
fine bookmark that we need one right
there right next to the plasti cells and
so such a thing is a cultural artifact
which doesn't just appear out of nowhere
it hasn't it has to have a context it
has to have a background and again my
suggestion would be perhaps a secret
technology it's very odd that very few
of these have been found and it may be
that ship owners and navigators in Greek
times were extremely careful about who
they shared this technology we're course
it may be they may it may have been as
top secret as you know nuclear power is
in in in our world today how that makes
sense but the fact is that then we have
to it exists it's real it's there yeah
and then we must consider what's behind
it what what led to that is that just
the latest manifestation of something
that that goes much more deeply back
into human human culture and I think
that is I think I suppose my main my
main message is that we have a so far
untold backstory that we're
concentrating entirely on the front
story and the back story is missing very
largely missing from the picture and
what I've tried to do is to fill in bits
of the backstory do you have anything in
this book about the omics no not really
I I mentioned I mentioned them briefly
explored the Olmec mystery in
considerable depth did he explain that
to people maybe in fingerprints of the
gods
yes so it's considered to be the
earliest high culture of Central America
everybody's heard about the Aztecs
everybody's heard about the Maya but
before the Aztecs and before the Maya
there were a culture who are referred to
as the Olmecs again we don't know what
they called themselves that's what the
Aztecs called them they called them the
Olmecs and it means the rubber people
because they rub a producing area of of
Mexico they worked in giant megalithic
constructions that what they're most
famous for is these huge carved human
heads which can be on a scale of up to
20 to 25 tonnes in weight and and which
have curious features which have been
interpreted variously as Polynesian
African don't look like classic Native
American features but one of the things
one of the things I've realized is that
there is no classic Native American
feature that Native Americans are a very
have a very complex genetic story with
very many different elements brought
into it and we shouldn't be necessarily
surprised by the supposedly non-native
American look what maybe we think those
helmets were that they were wearing
nobody knows because no physical example
of such a helmet has ever been found
just like no physical example of an
Egyptian pharaohs helm a crown has it
has ever been found all we see is the
stone the stone reproductions of them do
they universally were these helmets they
actually pretty much all wear these
helmets in in in in the Olmec stonework
there's another fascinating figure from
La Venta one of one of the Olmec sites
which is the earliest ever image of a
plumed or feathered serpent the
feathered serpent is a famous icon in
Central America Quetzalcoatl who's the
the god of peace the bringer of
civilization who is associated for
example with the famous pyramid of
kukulcan which is just another name for
Quetzalcoatl at Chichen itzá
on the spring equinox a shadow effect
creates the image of a serpent coiling
down the stairway and joining with the
carved head of the serpent oh the Bears
the the image from La Venta that's the
earliest image of a plumed serpent in
the Americas
and sitting in the middle of it and I
made a big deal out of this because I
think it is a big deal in magicians of
the Gods sitting in the middle of it is
this human figure who's holding this
strange bag in his hand and it's just a
fact that those identical bags are found
in ancient Sumer in the hands of
individuals who were considered to be
civilization bringers and they also show
up on pillar 43 at gobekli tepe
I call them man bags and in that case it
gobekli tepe we know there at least
eleven thousand six hundred years old so
I wonder if we're looking at a sort of
badge of office of a group of civilizer
x' who travelled around the world trying
to bring back to life a lost
civilization and passed down I deploy a
concept in this book that I actually got
from Richard Dawkins Richard Richard
Dawkins is the author of the book called
The Selfish Gene and he's not one of my
favorite people because he's a he's a
materialist reductionist and he doesn't
believe in spirit or or any mystery in
life that were just accidents of
chemistry and beer and biology he also
has no psychedelic experience and he
said no I did challenge him at a public
event two to go to go have a dozen
sessions of ayahuasca yes at once oh
just once but he has an excellent out
because and sadly he's had that he's had
a stroke so he has a good excuse for not
for not doing that but he is a clever
man and one of his concepts that he's
introduced into human culture is the
concept of the meme we're off of I think
familiar with that where genes are
physical reproductive mechanisms they
reproduce themselves down the
generations they replicate they multiply
they're passed on from one individual to
another memes are cultural objects
cultural ideas that are passed on and
replicate and reproduce themselves and
what I see right across the Americas and
right across the old world as well is a
set of memes that involve the sky that
involved the ground that involve
geometry that involve notions of life
after death and I think the only way to
explain these is that they have been
inherited from an earlier culture
in some way connected with the ancestors
of all of these all of these cultures I
think that's what we're looking at in
the Amazon we're looking at a meme which
was deliberately created once you
mobilize a population to start creating
huge geometrical structures you are also
facilitating many other possibilities
that an organized population allows I
think that's what happened at gobekli
tepe
I think that's why they created the
megalithic site there to mobilize the
local population of hunter-gatherers to
give them a project to do to engage them
and in the process of engaging them to
teach them the skills of Agriculture
which were which which are fundamental
to to any concept of of civilization and
it's weird the way agriculture just
suddenly appears in in gobekli tepe
and there's huge agricultural mysteries
in the Amazon as well may I share a
couple of these mysteries with you
before you do that though can you pull
up that image from gobekli tepe of
pillar was a pillar 43 pillar 43 in
enclosure D I would like to see that
that guy holding that bag that is its
that the bags are in a row along the top
of the pillar
it's pillar 43 in an enclosure D that
Gobekli Tepe is there an image of that
online that's available okay here we go
yeah there's so there's the bag in a row
in a row along the top it's the same
sort of square shaped bag with a curved
handle that you find on the earliest
image of the pillar of the feathered
serpent and that you find no you have to
go above that Jamie just a little bit
higher up the pillar those max right
Yeah right it right at the top there
it's odd that this symbol crops up in in
many different cultures and tends to be
associated with mainstream
interpretation of those present there is
no mainstream interpretation of those
banks that's my interpretation of those
banks which I which I freely confess
that's how that's how I read them I'm
intrigued by the anomaly that the
similar bagging turns up in the hands of
the Quetzalcoatl finger and turns up in
Mesopotamia repeatedly in in the hands
of the individual so called the AB kallu
the the magician's of the gods the
beginner bringers of civilization and
the plume serpent Quetzalcoatl was it's
an Aztec card right and questa è questo
qui tollis an Aztec is an Aztec
but but the Aztecs acquired him from
earlier cultures the very fact that an
image of the plumed serpent is given
such priority in Olmec culture tells us
that that system of ideas was present
during Olmec times which takes us back
at least to 1500 BC probably quite a bit
earlier than that where's the Aztecs are
1500 AD so there's 3000 years between
the Aztecs and the Olmecs and that same
system of ideas is running through all
of those cultures and the Mayans had a
name for it as well kukulcan and what do
you think that plumed serpent was I
think he's it's very clear from from the
accounts that have survived that what
he's associated with her two things in
particular one of them he's a God of
peace he's not a war god and the and the
other thing that he's primarily about is
giving the gifts of civilization this is
what you human beings need to know in
order to move on to the next level that
is that is the function and the role of
Quetzalcoatl and it's there are very
similar we could refer to them as
civilizing heroes who are found in other
cultures and other locations or cyrus in
egypt plays that role as a bringer of
civilization there's hardly a culture in
the ancient world that doesn't remember
a time far back in remote prehistory
when some kind of supernaturals or
advanced human beings and I prefer the
latter that some kind of advanced human
beings were involved in a project to
disseminate civilization I mentioned the
Takano in the Amazon who who are big
drinkers of of ayahuasca the Takano have
a fascinating origin myth they say that
they're ant the origin myth states
specifically that their ancestors were
brought to the Amazon they were brought
to the Amazon by a group of
supernaturals who included the daughter
of the son and an individual called the
helmsman who steered the serpent canoe
in which this settlement mission in the
Amazon was was performed and what these
so-called supernaturals did was they
brought the ancestors of duquan Oh to
the Amazon and they showed them the best
places
settle the best places where they where
they might find hunting the best places
where they might create a village the
best places for agriculture and then
they left
but they left them behind one gift and
that gift was ayahuasca that's the story
of the origin myth of the Takano and it
sounds to me rather like the other side
of the story of that DNA signal in the
Amazon that a group of people were
deliberately settled in the Amazon by
human beings who they chose to regard as
a supernatural
that's that's what makes sense of it to
me when I interrupted you to talk about
Quetzalcoatl when what were you about to
say I'm in California I've been smoking
dope yeah we were talking about
different things in the Amazon should we
rewind and figure out exactly the
surfing Cod you're talking about before
Quetzalcoatl before that I have another
question
the Olmecs did you were talking about
the genetics of these people that live
and Native Americans that they vary
widely but the Olmecs seemed to have
very similar features the thick lips the
big noses why do we think that is well
this is part of a curious mystery that
is not unconnected to the genetic
mystery it's been known by archeologists
for quite a long time that there are
anomalous skulls in parts of Brazil
which appear to show very strongly
Polynesian or African features very much
like the features that we see on the on
the Olmec heads and a number of
archeologists who got into trouble with
their colleagues for this have used that
to argue many years ago 3040 years ago
that that the settlement story of the
Americas is much more complicated than
we've you know then we then we've
realized and and what the what the DNA
is doing is it's telling us that there
was something really weird happened
happened with settlement they you see
what happened with those African or
Polynesian looking skulls was that they
were tested for DNA
when DNA technology was not as advanced
as it is today and what that DNA showed
was that they were more closely related
to modern Native Americans than they are
to any other people in the world so the
notion that there was some connection
with Polynesia or Africa was dismissed
but now that we have very firm evidence
of an Australasian genetic signal of
Australian Aborigines Papua New Guinea
Melanesians with those kind of features
now that we have the genetic evidence
that that is found in the Amazon we have
to go back to that old evidence and and
reconsider it Wow yeah I would love to
find out what that is that they've
always fascinated me then the Olmecs
it's always been such a strange image
the the large heads with new helmets on
them and how do they universally look
like that I mean they although all of
the features are very very similar very
very similar always with the helmet and
almost always I won't claim that every
single Olmec head has a helmet oh
because I think I've seen one that
didn't it's quite a while ago since I
explored the the Olmec area but what's
fascinating about them is they are they
are supposedly the first high
civilization of Central America that
they create structures on a massive
scale that you can see connections
between them and the later the later
Maya that whole mystery of the Mayan
calendar was clearly inherited from the
Olmecs it wasn't something the Maya made
up the rmx used that same symbolism so
the Mayan calendar is actually an Olmec
calendar and if we then consider the
possibility that the Olmecs may just be
the latest that the earliest surviving
manifestation of that calendar it could
go back much further than that do you
plan on having any debates with people
that opposed these ideas well it was
interesting on your very show Joe - to
have the debate that involved Michael
Shermer who's the editor of the skeptic
magazine and some colleague of his who
came in on mine yeah who I got a bit
annoyed with and myself and my great
friend and colleague the genius Randall
Carson
and I felt that that was a very useful
debate I felt that it's possibly the
first time that those of us on the
alternative side of the argument about
history where were given an opportunity
really to put our evidence forward and
to confront so-called skeptics well it's
so cold that's what he calls himself
Michael Shermer with this evidence and
yeah obviously I'm biased but I I don't
feel that he fielded the situation
particularly well I don't think
mainstream archeology came out of that
looking really good I think it came out
of that looking rather ignorant and and
uninformed and and a man like Michael
Shermer who is a professional skeptic
cannot begin to match the knowledge of a
man like Randall Carson who has devoted
his whole life to walking the walk of
the geology of the end of the Ice Age in
in in North America and that showed on
on that debate so I think the debate was
worth doing I think it showed that the
alternative side isn't just wishy-washy
stuff out there on the fringes of things
that there are those of us working in
this field who are using really solid
information and who are who our project
is to rewrite history and we're not
going to do that with slight information
it has to be solid information I think
we had the opportunity on your show to
to say that that that solid information
is there I'm not claiming it was a
complete victory for the alternative
site Michael Shermer is a smart guy and
he put forward some good arguments too
and there were constructive aspects of
that debate which I which I appreciated
I'd like to see much more engagement and
much more positive approach I wish the
skeptics welcome to their skepticism but
I wish they'd be less hateful less less
full of derision less less despising
well they're so defensive with their
ideas and and so and so defensive with
their ideas when the possibility is
there for for a constructive debate you
know well what's interesting to me is
that as this evidence piles up and it
seems to be continuing to pile up as
more like the these impact sites and
more of this ancient civilization
material gets unearthed it's almost
instrum
yeah it's officer and this is how this
is how paradigms shift I mean
everybody's familiar with the concept of
a paradigm shift and there's a book
called the structure of scientific
revolutions by Thomas Kuhn which
outlines what a paradigm shift is where
an established model in some discipline
of science that has been in control of
people's thinking for a very long time
suddenly falls apart
and it doesn't fall apart suddenly what
happens is that there's an accumulation
of evidence which that model cannot
explain that paradigm cannot explain it
it seemed like a great paradigm at one
point but then it doesn't explain this
and then it doesn't explain like like
the paradigm that says that megalithic
architecture is only six thousand years
old and that the first megalithic
architecture was in Malta that can't
explain the massive megalithic site of
Gobekli Tepe in Turkey five thousand
five hundred years before that it's
evidence like that the slow accumulation
of evidence that the existing system
cannot explain that ad eventual point no
matter how strongly the advocates of the
existing system hold on to it no matter
how determined they are in their defense
no matter what dirty tricks they may
choose to deploy to undermine their
opponents sooner or later the evidence
overwhelms them and the paradigm goes
down and you have a new way of thinking
and that that is the story of science
and it is a story that I think I think
we're at a tipping point in our
understanding of the past of the human
species I am NOT saying that I am 100
percent right I believe that what what
I'm doing that's worthwhile is I'm
asking questions about the past that
haven't been asked enough I'm putting
archaeologists on the spot and and
demanding that they explain themselves I
don't I don't claim that I'm right I'm
offering an alternative theory and my
objective is to get people to think for
themselves to think about this stuff and
not to accept the voice of authority as
that as the sole medium of truth that's
that's what I've tried to do have you
had any archaeologist review any of this
work and changed their opinions no no I
haven't but what I what I have found and
I found it interestingly during the
research trips for America before is a
younger generation of archaeologists who
in the field and they are quite
different from the older generation of
archaeologists who were running the
whole scene 25 years ago now we have a
very different younger generation a
younger generation that has been exposed
to open-minded thinking that has been
exposed to the Internet that itself as
part of the general pattern of the
younger generation is suspicious of
authority
I'm meeting young archaeologists on
sites for example I met a couple of
really amazing young minds on a site
called Blackwater draw in Arizona New
Mexico where where the one of the first
Clovis sites the the young
archaeologists I met there were
incredibly open mind and really willing
to consider extraordinary possibilities
about the past and privately admitted to
me that they'd read my books
well that's where I get the hope I get
the hope in this young generation that
is growing up with the internet that
does understand that there's a lot more
out there than just what they're being
taught in schools yes yeah this is this
this is where the where the hope lies
and it lies in in every area and it's
white one of the one of the intriguing
things that has happened with me and
your show is an important part of this
is that when I go around giving public
events doing a public presentation of my
work the demography of the audiences is
extremely interesting and this is true
whether I'm giving the talk in Britain
whether I'm giving it in Canada whether
I'm giving it in America part of the
audience are older people who read me in
the 1990s who got onto my work with
fingerprints of the gods in 1995 and
they've stuck with me and they've
carried on reading my work but another
part of the audience are a very big part
of the audience consists to a large
extent of young people most of whom are
men but there are women amongst them as
well and what those mainly young men
come up to me and say at the end of the
event is we first encountered your work
on Joe Rogan's show and it completely
opened our minds it changed it I've had
so many young men say this has changed
my life and then I ask myself well why
should a different take on the past
change people's lives why should people
feel that their lives have been changed
by a different take on the
which I add they would not know about
unless you'd had the good grace to bring
me on that on on your show this these
ideas would not be known but they are
known because of the amazing outreach of
your show and the answer to that
question why does it why does it change
a person's life is that once we realize
that we have been misinformed about our
past that everything that we've built
our idea of who we are upon and of where
we're going as a culture may be founded
on falsehoods and perhaps even
deliberate lies once that is realized
then all the questions about the nature
of the society we live in become open
and and people young people are feeling
the need to take an independent path not
to not to follow the path that has been
set down for them by previous
generations and in some way and I'm very
gratified to hear this the fact that I'm
an elder now I'm 69 next next birthday
the fact that I look great thank you the
fact that I as an elder have
consistently pursued an independent past
part have been willing to put up with
the [ __ ] that's been thrown at me over
the years but have stuck to my guns and
have continued to add new information to
the dosia of information that I put
forward that is and I'm encouraged to
see this that's found as inspiring by
younger people and what what better gift
could an old guy hope to leave to the
world than a younger generation who feel
inspired by that person's work to change
the world
well I'm very very thankful that I could
introduce people to you because your
first book that I read of you
fingerprints of the gods changed my view
of the world I mean I remember putting
that book down after I was finishing
going wow like if he is right like this
whole thing is a mess yeah a complete
mess
because our idea of who we are is very
much founded in our idea of who we were
and and one of I think one of the
mistakes that's made in our civilization
is that we are very conceited we're very
big headed and we tend to review the
view the whole story of history as
though it's a project that leads to us
that we're what it's all about
and I think what is what is how can I
put it undermining of the existing
system about a new take on the past is
the notion that we're not what it's all
about at all that there may have been an
earlier civilization that reached a high
level of advancement perhaps different
from ours but nevertheless an advanced
civilization which was just taken out of
the story completely by a global
Cataclysm then we suddenly we suddenly
realized that in a way we're here
accidentally that it's not been a
process that's been all about us and and
that if we've been misinformed about how
we got here then we need to get the
truly information about about what's
going on so so these are in a way
profoundly revolutionary ideas they do
they do lead people on a path of inquiry
that leads to questioning of everything
and our fears that you were just
discussing earlier about how soft we are
in comparison to past civilizations in
terms of like our ability to live off
the land that's one aspect that bothers
me but one of the big ones that bothers
me is the fact that everything is
digital all of our information is stored
on hard drives you bet and if that goes
down there's not much left you have
paper books and and you know a few
thousands of years imagine what would be
left yeah we would lose all of our
advancement well I can I can speak to
this at a personal level there was a
time when I was an excellent map reader
and I I I could navigate anywhere with
with maps you know my wife Santa and I
did huge journeys in Mexico back in the
early 1990s in really cheap hire cars
with maps and we found our way
everywhere without any problem today I
can hardly use a map the skill of using
a map has elapsed within me why because
of GPS GPS technology has come along and
it's and it always tells me where I am
and being a bit lazy I just accept that
that technology but then I had cause to
ask myself this just the other day
supposing GPS supposing all those
satellites go down and there's no GPS is
the hole the hole
all industrialized human race is going
to suddenly be lost all those uber
drivers who don't know their way from A
to B and who rely entirely on their GPS
is they won't know they won't know where
they're going and it's and it's true
with digital data the digit digital data
unlike unlike print data is very fragile
and requires programs in order to access
and interpret it that are much more
complicated than simply cracking the
code of a lost language I mean the
programs vary between different phone
platforms a varied computer platforms
it's just it's so fragile and it's so I
mean I don't know if there's any
precautions that have been taking place
to preserve this information in case of
like what Robert Schoch described a
coronal mass ejection or something clear
down all the satellites yeah no I don't
think I don't think preparation has been
made and I don't and I don't and it's
very clear that that preparation is not
being made for the risk of another
cosmic impact and again a point that I'd
like to make about this is that we are
it we are in a sense in a place where
history can repeat itself that there are
certain cycles at work the work on the
comet impact twelve thousand eight
hundred years ago has very clearly and
specifically identified the debris trail
of that comment and that debris trail is
the torrid meteor stream and it's called
the torrid meteor stream because it
appears to emanate from the region of
the sky in which the constellation of
Taurus sits it doesn't it's within our
solar system it's an optical illusion
the torrid meteor stream is a giant
complex of debris it is 30 million
kilometres wide what you had was an
original comet that might have been a
hundred to two hundred kilometres in
diameter a small moon which fragmented
and broke up into multiple multiple
parts and those parts began to spread
out along the whole orbit of the torrid
meteor stream and to widen the whole
thing widened so it's like a giant tube
of debris and the evidence and the
argument is that twelve thousand eight
hundred years ago several large bits of
that debris fell out of the torrid
meteor stream and impacted with the
earth
the problem is that the torrid meteor
stream still exists and our planet still
passes through it twice a year and those
passages take place in June and in
November and each passage takes 12 and a
half days and the same group of
scientists who are who are looking at
the evidence for the impacts twelve
thousand eight hundred years ago are
deeply concerned that we may face future
impacts from the torrid meteor stream
that there are still large objects up
there this is not theory this is a fact
there's a comet up there called comet
Encke II which is part of the torrid
meteor stream it's a large fragment of
the original giant comet comet Encke II
has a diameter of I don't know five or
five or six kilometres there's there's
nineteen recognized huge objects within
the torrid meet history in calculations
indicate that there may be as much as
200 asteroids within the torrid meteor
stream of a diameter of a kilometer or
more which would have catastrophic
effect if they if they hit the earth and
responsible astronomers regard the
torrid meteor stream as the greatest
collision hazard facing mankind at the
present time and it's not something that
we need to fall into despair about
because it's perfectly within the level
of our technology to do something about
it
what could they do well to give you an
example commercial interests are looking
right now and the technology is there to
mine asteroids we can go to asteroids if
the if the commercial interest is high
enough we can go to them we can mine
them we can extract minerals we can
bring them back to the earth the same
technology would allow you to move
asteroids or comets fragments you don't
want to blow them up with a nuke that
would be a really bad idea that would
that would turn one large object into
multiple smaller objects which could
cause equally massive devastation and
and would be very difficult to predict
where that devastation was going to fall
what you want to do is to nudge them and
move them out of a dangerous orbit into
into a less dangerous orbit and and and
the evidence is in the next thirty years
we are going to be passing through
dangerous filaments of the toward meteor
stream and if we were smart we would be
devoting some resources to protecting
our cosmic environment just as where
there are many issues that we need to
devote resources to unfortunately the
one that's most attractive to
politicians at the moment is warfare we
devote limitless resources to
technologies of mass destruction there
really is no end to the amount that
we're prepared to spend on that in terms
of our so-called security we feel
somehow we're making ourselves more
secure by having these incredible
weapons and spending trillions of
dollars on them but the cosmos doesn't
give a [ __ ] about any of that the cosmos
is out there with these with these giant
giant objects which have a far greater
explosive power than all the nuclear
weapons stored on earth at the present
time the comet shoemaker-levy 9 which
hit Jupiter in 1994 had a total
calculated explosive power of 300 Giga
tons if you took the entire nuclear
arsenal of the world today and blew it
all up at once it would yield 6.4 Giga
tons so these objects are producing
catastrophic results on a scale that far
far beyond anything that we ourselves
could do with nuclear weapons it's time
we spent a bit less time and money on
weapons of mass destruction and a bit
more on looking after this beautiful
garden that we call the earth and there
is our home and it will be the home of
our children and our children's children
I'm a grandfather now I feel
passionately about this we need to look
after this planet it's our
responsibility as a human species to do
so and one of the challenges it's not
the only challenge there are many many
other challenges one of the challenges
is to pay attention to our cosmic
environment and to realize that the
cosmos can intervene cataclysmically in
the human story and that the torrid
meteor stream in particular may have
been a hidden hand in human history that
there may have been other impacts in the
last 13,000 years that affect have
affected and changed the course of
humanity on this earth and the ancients
were very good at paying attention to
the sky
we ourselves have amazing tech to study
the sky but for some reason we're
ignoring this problem of cosmic impacts
and that's incredibly irresponsible
because as I said a moment ago it is a
solvable problem it is within the limits
of our technology it would require a
global cooperative effort to sweep our
cosmic environment clean but it could be
done and a sigh
product of that global cooperation might
be a friendlier more nurturing more
loving more positive human community it
is very odd that we have this infantile
nature even as grown adults and world
leaders that we don't we do like to nor
imminent danger as long as it hasn't
affected us in the past yes there's no
real moment we can point to other than
Tunguska in you know photographic
history or modern history where you
could take pictures of things we had and
if I can if I can pause you on that very
point the evidence is compelling that
the Tunguska event was an object that
fell out of the torrid meteor stream
that happened at the peak of the bethe
turrets in June 1908 the it is extremely
likely that that Tunguska object came
from the torrid meteor stream because we
were passing through the torrid media
stream at exactly that time and what the
Tunguska object is estimated to be
between sixty and a hundred and ninety
meters in diameter so it's not a very
big object it's not a kilometer scale
object it's it's it's it's big but it's
not that big it doesn't even hit the
earth it it's an air burst it explodes
in the sky above fortunately an
uninhabited area of Siberia but the
devastation is huge it wasn't even
noticed for some years afterwards until
scientific teams went in and studied the
area and discovered that 80 million
trees across 2,000 square kilometers had
been completely flattened by that air
burst and to put that in context 2,000
square kilometres is the size of London
so anybody who knows London is aware
that there's a ring road around London
called the m25 if that air burst had
taken place over central London
everything of London out as far as the
m25 would have been gone completely is
that what it looks like today pretty
close like hundred years later there's
no trees and whites that were taken in
the early nineteen which which revealed
the extent of this of this damage so
it's just stupid of us not to pay a bit
more attention to this especially when
we have the tech to actually do
something about it we have that
that nature though when it comes to
climate change as a curious denial
there's a denial of the role of
cataclysms in the human story and there
there is even a word for that in science
and it's called uniformitarianism and
and this is a particular philosophy of
science where the view is that
everything as we see it in the world
today is how things have always been so
if we don't see cataclysms today and
they're not playing a major part in our
story today then there weren't
cataclysms and they didn't play a major
part in our story in the past that's why
although it's before the time of human
beings when the evidence that the
dinosaurs were made extinct by a comet
or an asteroid first came out luis and
walter alvarez the father-son team who
were behind that science were ridiculed
man their colleagues and they were told
it's absolutely absurd of course no
cosmic event could have made the
dinosaurs extinct they spent ten years
taking that ridicule until they found
the crater in the Gulf of Mexico since
then the whole scientific community has
accepted that the course of life on this
planet was radically changed by a cosmic
impact and you know I like to joke about
it but it was a cosmic impact that was
big enough literally to turn dinosaurs
into chickens because that's what's left
of the time so life is you know the
birds and at the same time skulking in
those primeval forests is this little
mammal and it looks a bit like a shrew
65 million years ago going nowhere the
dinosaurs ruled the earth then the
cosmos intervenes the dinosaurs are
swept out of the way and what happens
the mammals start to evolve very rapidly
and they start to occupy niches that
were previously closed to them and the
bottom line is we would not be here the
human species would not be here we would
not be having this conversation if the
dinosaurs had not been made extinct 65
million years ago so these are
world-changing events and my argument is
that such a world-changing event
occurred between twelve thousand eight
hundred and eleven thousand six hundred
years ago and it's high time we paid
more attention to it is there any
evidence that there was other species of
human beings that existed in the
America's like we're finding in Russia
and there's many of them that are being
discovered all over the world now these
subspecies human beings
yeah this is an issue that I go into in
in America before and what first drew me
into it was Denisova cave in Siberia
I think everybody's heard of the
Neanderthals and these days I think
everybody's heard of the Denisovans as
well a lot of people have a lot of well
I guess a lot of people haven't but but
first of all let's take the Neanderthals
for a long time it was held that the
Neanderthals were stupid primitive
subhumans shambling lacking symbolism
turns out that that's not true at all
the latest scientific on evidence on the
Neanderthals is that they were symbolic
creatures that they did do art that they
were in every sense human and they were
in every sense human because
anatomically modern humans interbred
with Neanderthals you can't interbreed
with another species they they clearly
were human beings but they looked rather
different from us and that's why certain
populations in the world today still
have three to five percent of
Neanderthal DNA then in Russia in
Denisova cave they find a single pinky
bone from a little finger and they do
the DNA testing on it they're able to
get a complete genome from it and what
they discover is this isn't in the and
earth all this isn't an anatomically
modern human being this is another human
species who they named the Denisovans
they think they're more closely related
to Neanderthals than they are to
anatomically modern humans but they're
clearly another human species and they
also interbred with anatomically modern
humans and Denisovan DNA survives
interestingly enough it survives
predominantly in Australasia in Papua
New Guinea and amongst Australian
Aborigines so as part of the research
for this book I went to Denisova cave I
had an amazing actually just incredible
trip to Russia I hadn't hadn't expected
it to be like that at all Siberia I mean
America is vast but my god crossing
Siberia this is endless rolling plains
you know this
just vast area how much cross we took a
car
well you can't travel independently in
Russia it's very difficult you have to
get you have to get permission and you
have to state in advance where you're
going to be stopping off that so what I
found and I just did so through the
internet was a was a local guy called
Sergey Coogan who had a little tour
business in in in Siberia in the city of
Novosibirsk I got in touch with him he
found a translator who would translate
my emails and I said we want to make
this journey to Denisova cave and can
you set this up for us and get all the
permissions and and he did and so we
flew into Novosibirsk
Sergey and his translator who turned out
to be a Russian student who spoke good
English joined us and we did this
immense journey across Siberia
oh it took us three days to get to to
get to Denisova cave three days three
days of driving every day so I'm
stopping off along the way incredible
hospitality of the of the Russians that
we were were amongst very independent
people people who are living out there
in the wilderness and who actually do do
know how to survive it's the first time
I've ever drunk milk fresh from the cow
literally milked right out of the cow
and poured down my throat I was it was
delicious and a cream I mean thick cream
there was a lot of things about Russia
that surprised me Denisova cave is a
fascinating beautiful place to visit
it's another it's another example of a
missing chapter in the human story that
is beginning to be pieced together it's
obvious now that we were not alone that
there were multiple other human species
who were human enough to interbreed with
us and leave leave DNA and this
Denisovan species was only discovered in
like was it 2000 so I'm very recently
the 2007 it's a very it's a very recent
discovery and and is it behind our hmm
did they leave behind art better than
that they they left behind certain
physical objects which are extremely
hard to explain one of them is a green
stone bracelet and that bracelet is in
the form of a talk which was therefore
slipped on sideways onto the hand it's
not a full ring and a hole has been
drilled through the brace
it and from that hole it's been possible
to reconstruct that a pendant was hung
then the archeologists there it is then
the archaeologists started to take a
look in detail at the drill marks on
that hole and what they discovered was a
huge anomaly that that was drilled with
a stable fixed drill and it was drilled
at extremely high speed it's a this is
thought to be 40 or 50 thousand years
old there is not supposed to have been
any such technology in that period that
was capable of drilling with a stable
fixed drill and yet there it is and
there it appears so there there are also
incredible very fine needles bone
needles that the Denisovans made very
long ones which suggests that they were
stitching very heavy stuff together and
the suggestion has been were they making
skin boats for example to use to
navigate that would explain how they
managed to get themselves to Australia
which is where the largest amount of
Denisovan DNA survives today there's one
of those there's one of those needles so
that there are indications of strangely
out of place technology amongst the
Denisovans which is twenty thirty
thousand years earlier in the human
story than it than it should be those
kind of needles that kind of bracelet
you could expect to find them in what
archaeologists call the Neolithic but to
find it in the Paleolithic is very
puzzling and very odd and it suggests
that the Denisovans were certainly not
shambling sub-sub humans that they were
refined creatures can you find out what
year they discovered the Denisovans
Jamie can you google that real quick I
don't want to say it's in the 2000s but
I mean imagine that human beings have
been around for this long here we are in
2019 and within the last decade or so
they figured this out yeah we're
discovering new stuff about ourselves
we're discovering that our story is much
richer much more textured much more led
than we thought it was it's not a simple
story it's a very complicated story and
we ourselves are a hybrid species we are
we are the result of interactions with
all kinds of different looking human
beings and the end the end result is
ourselves so it's not just that we carry
Neanderthal or Denisovan DNA in a sense
we are in the end of
and Denisovans you know and have that
there they are part of the anatomically
modern human human heritage so you make
a good point
the fact that this is only being
discovered now and that it's an
incredibly important I mean it it
completely rewrites the story of our
ancestry the notion the note in 1917 70s
okay where the real work that's been
done in Denisova cave has been done in
the 2000s from from 2006 2007 all
genetics that's when the major papers
have been 2008 there have been published
yeah which of which have revealed the
genome of the Denisovans and revealed
the Denisovan connection to to
anatomically modern humans the fact that
we're only finding this out now that we
that we told the story of our past and
weren't aware of this raises the
question how much else in the story of
our past is there that we are not aware
of let's stop being so arrogant so sure
of ourselves so confident in our
findings that's been more tentative
let's keep an open mind and see and see
where it takes us that's that's the main
message that I have from from all of
this and I think and I hope that this
will be an effect of this book I'm not
I'm not kidding myself that the
archaeologists are going to jump on
board
overnight particularly so since I'm very
critical of American archaeology in this
book and I'm critical of it specifically
and explicitly because of the dominance
of the Clovis first model for so long
which prevented other research taking
place and I have to say archaeologists
like to insult me by calling me a pseudo
scientist I can't think of anything more
pseudo scientific than the Clovis first
doctrine which locked American
archaeology for 50 years in a particular
framework which we now know was totally
wrong nothing good about it at all a
complete mistake what I'm hoping the
book will do in the long run is that it
will lead to more attention being
focused on the Americas this is a very
neglected area of the world as far as
deep and ancient archaeology goes I'm
it's the recent history of the Americas
has been relative
well studied but the deep and ancient
history has not been has not been well
studied and I think America is going to
contain revelations for us about our
story and about our past and I'm serious
when I when I suggest that America is
the most plausible and the most likely
home base for a lost civilization if
you're going to propose a lost
civilization you need there are certain
preconditions you need a you can't have
it on a small island there's got to be a
large landmass with enormous resources
and the ability for population to grow
and for those resources to be to be
mobilized and what I suddenly realize
you asked earlier why I why I started to
write this book at all is what the new
evidence is pointing to is that the
Americas have been wrongly neglected
that here we have a giant continental
landmass with extraordinary resources
that has just been ruled out of the
story of human civilization but once we
take account of the fact that there was
a giant Cataclysm over North America
twelve thousand eight hundred years ago
once we start looking as I do in America
before at the incredible deep in-depth
similarities between for example the
religious system of ancient Egypt and
the religious system of the Mississippi
Valley then you realize that you're into
a into a global mystery here and that
the answer to that mystery may not at
all be in the old world and may very
much be in the in the Americas see it's
odd I mentioned Marvel earlier on it's
kind of odd that we should find what is
essentially the ancient Egyptian
religion manifesting in the symbolism of
Moundville the ascent to Orion that
transit to the Milky Way the journey
along the Milky Way very these are very
specific and idiosyncratic ideas and
what makes it doubly odd is Marvel isn't
that old Marvel as a site is about a
thousand years old ancient Egypt had
already been gone completely from the
world for at least 600 years before
Marvel was created the end of ancient
Egypt there's Marvel and what we're
looking at in the foreground is mound B
and we're looking at mound a
the in the in the distance and a
complete circle of mounds what what is
odd about it is we find this system of
ancient Egyptian ideas in Marvel 500
years after ancient Egypt has gone from
the world the Romans the the Romans were
the end of ancient Egypt by 400 AD
ancient Egypt is gone Marvel doesn't
even exist them but 600 years later it
is created and it manifests the entire
set of ancient Egyptian ideas clearly it
did not get that as a result of direct
transmission from ancient Egypt unless
they were time travelers the only way I
think it could have got it is as a
result of a legacy passed down from a
much earlier civilization that had been
influenced and affected many different
parts of the world and the
characteristics of that civilization
there's the shamanistic heart of it the
use of altered states of consciousness
the focus on those are amongst the
reasons that I would suggest that
America is the place that we should be
looking and the big mysteries are in the
areas that were so devastated at the end
of the last ice age up in the north of
North America the channeled scablands in
particular and then the Mississippi
Valley the whole story of the
Mississippi Valley yes Moundville is a
thousand years old but then you can go
back to Poverty Point in Louisiana which
is 2700 years old you can go to Watson
break in Louisiana which is five
thousand five hundred years old you can
go to sites like Conley which are 8,000
years old the system keeps on going back
and disappearing back into time and I
think the most fruitful new work on
exploring the origins of civilization is
going to occur
counter-intuitively in the Americas the
very last place on earth that
archeologists have ever thought to look
where damn what do mainstream
archeologists what do they think caused
those drill marks and the Denisovan
bracelets it not really explained it the
the Russian the Russian archaeologists
who published the report on that are
them are themselves mystified by it and
they realize that it's dynamite it's an
it's an explosive discovery it's a it's
an out of place technology and so
they're trying to explain how come fixed
stable drilling which we thought was
introduced first in the in the
lithic maybe seven eight thousand years
ago how come that is now found in a site
that's forty or fifty thousand years old
that's how all those bracelets oh yeah
absolutely
those bracelets are forty thousand under
may they may have been older there's
there's those recent research suggests
suggesting that they may go back
sixty-five to seventy thousand years
that they're extremely ancient and
therefore and therefore they're
incorporating an out-of-place technology
which doesn't fit with the timeline of
history that we realize how out of place
at one very very out of place
very very very odd feature that we have
here so what this says to me is that we
as a species and I've this I guess this
is kind of my pet phrase we are a
species with amnesia it's my favorite
phrase which we have forgotten so much
more about ourselves than we remember
and what the process of history and
archaeology should really be about is a
process of remembering we shouldn't be
imposing our ideas of what we should
have been on the past we should allow
the past to speak for itself and when it
does so it speaks eloquently one of the
sites that we visited and explored for
America before was Serpent Mound in Ohio
I don't if you've ever been there you
know I've heard of it though it is an
amazing Jaimee's from ohio you ever be
there Serpent Mound
there's that there's an aerial view that
is crazy
here's the thing beautiful you see the
head end of Serpent Mound there so Santa
and I went there at the summer solstice
in 2017 we were there on June 21st 2017
and my wife's antha is a photographer
and we acquired a drone for this
specific purpose and she flew the drone
up 400 feet above Serpent Mound and we
sat it up there watching the sunset and
what happens on the summer solstice and
you can only see it perfectly with a
drone there's pictures of it in the in
the book here what happens on the summer
solstice you can see it from ground
level but you get up 400 feet you really
get it the head of that serpent is
pointing directly at a niche in the
distant Hills through which the sunsets
on the summer solstice on the longest
day of the year so it's a it's a sky
ground alignment a perfection that is
that is taking place there it's a
beautiful it's a beautiful thing to see
to watch that Sun majestically sinking
down into the horizon and see this
awesome figure of the serpent gazing
directly of at it with its jaws open
almost as though it's about to about to
swallow the Sun and then we remember
that there are other sites around the
world which are also aligned to key
moments of the of the solar year aligned
to the winter solstice for example the
Temple of Karnak in Upper Egypt that
kilometer long axis targets exactly the
rising point of the Sun on the winter
solstice one of the interesting things
about serpent mound and I urge anybody
listening to this go visit Serpent Mound
and especially go there on the summer
solstice because that's the moment
that's the marriage of heaven and earth
that's when sky and ground unite in in
majesty at at that place but one of the
the mysteries of Serpent Mound concerns
how old is this mound really how far
back does it go and there have been
arguments that that there are as a group
of archaeologists who would like it to
be just a thousand years old and they
attributed to a culture called the fort
ancient culture there's another group of
archaeologists in my view have done much
more thorough thorough work who
attributed to the Idina culture the
thing about which goes back to 2300
years ago or so there's evidence for an
earlier construction enterprise it looks
like the site has been continuously
reconstructed and remodeled as we would
do with any sacred site if it begins to
wear down you remodel it and then you
get later organic material being
introduced to the site that may give you
the impression that the site is only
that old what's intriguing about Serpent
Mound is it stands on a natural ridge
and that natural ridge and this is
entirely an accident of heaven and earth
that natural ridge the head end of it if
you like is naturally oriented to the
summer solstice sunset somebody a long
time ago noticed that natural
orientation and they decided to manya
mentalize it here was a place where
earth whispered to sky the earth in her
own nature looked directly at the place
on the horizon where the Sun was setting
this was a highly significant place this
place matted so they then created
serpent mound on top of it they
memorialized it they turned it into a
into a special special place that human
beings had had hand in making to honor
the marriage of heaven and earth and
what I found researching this book is
that Serpent Mound is not alone in that
respect a lot of people are puzzled by
stonehenge in england stonehenge is
built on Salisbury Plain and there are
two kinds of big megaliths at stonehenge
one of them are called sarsens and the
other are called the blue stones the
blue stones we know for sure were
brought a long way they were brought
from Wales to Stonehenge a distance of
about 150 miles the sarsens are found in
abundance on a place called the
Marlborough downs which is about 20
miles from Stonehenge but until very
recently it was thought there were no
sarsens on Salisbury Plain at all an
archeologist couldn't understand why
Stonehenge wasn't built on the
Marlborough Downs whether whether big
sarsen stones the 20 to 30 tonne
megaliths were available locally and
didn't have to be brought there very
recent research 2018 research has
provided the answer that two of those
sarsens were naturally in position all
the time at Stonehenge and they are
sarsen stone 16 and the heel stone and
if you stand behind sarsen stone 16 and
look at the heel stone at dawn on the
summer solstice you see the Sun rising
in direct alignment with the view and
the heel stone is like the site on the
barrel of a rifle targeting the Sun and
that was there naturally earth was
speaking to sky the ancients saw that
they decided this was sacred
they went to huge lengths to bring the
sarsens the rest of the sarsens from the
Marlborough downs to create the big
stone circle at Stonehenge and then to
put the blue stones inside it but
initially what they were celebrating was
a natural union of heaven and earth and
that brings us to the notion of as above
so
below that we are connected to the
cosmos that it is that it is part of our
heritage we in modern cities forget the
cosmos exists we have all kinds of tech
that can look at the astronomy astronomy
programs we can we've all do that I'm
actually looking at the Stars is
something that's very difficult for
people who live in cities to do where
we're cut off from the cosmos we're cut
off from the notion that it is sacred
that it matters to the human creature
and what what the ancients seemed to
have done is to realize how vital that
connection is and to memorialize it and
to celebrate it and to draw our
attention to the intimate connection
between ground and sky yeah light
pollution sort of fuels our infantile
existence in a lot of ways right because
it doesn't constantly remind us that
we're a part of this great thing yeah
light light light pollution is a huge
factor it's very easy to forget that we
live in a universe very easy to forget
that very easy to believe that it's just
about these cities that we live in and
the and the intimate concerns of our of
our daily lives but we in fact we're
part of something much much bigger and
my god I mean it's it's a mystery enough
to be born a human being at all yes you
know just to be alive
is is an extraordinary mystery yes to
have the ability to to love to to feel
emotions to understand beauty to be
moved by by a symphony all of all of
these things we take for granted but
actually they're deeply mysterious we
don't really know what we are or or who
we are and which is one of the reasons
I'm so fascinated by Rick Strassman
'he's
where you you presented his film DMT the
spirit molecule and on my upcoming
speaking tour I'm going to be doing an
event with Rick on the 14th or 15th of
May in Sedona I think it'll be the first
time that Rick has spoken publicly for
quite a while rick has a colleague
called
andrew Gallimore who teaches at the
university of okinawa in japan and rick
and andrew have together developed a
technology for releasing DMT into human
volunteers
in a very slow drip that will keep them
in the dmt state if they wish for hours
on end and and the intention the
intention is to use this technology to
explore and map the DMT realm when do I
sign up
as soon as possible it's very close
Imperial College
it looks like Imperial College London is
going to deploy this technology in
further research into DMT and that that
research is not going to be purely and
simply into the therapeutic potential of
a psychedelic which is very important
research to do it's going to be an
investigation into the nature of reality
using a psychedelic the mysterious
nature of reality and it is art and you
know this from personal experience that
when you get plunged into that DMT realm
it is so different from the realm of our
daily daily world filled filled with
geometry filled with these sprightly
intelligences completely internally
coherent how can that be
you know generated by the brain or are
are we dealing with some other level of
reality that we haven't encountered yet
I think that ancient cultures and in
particular my lost civilization were
deeply involved in exploring the
mysterious nature of reality and used
the plant medicines as part of that
process when it comes to the serpent
mound where the head points in the
summer solstice is that take into
account the precession the equinoxes in
terms of position of the summer solstice
Sun on the horizon is not affected by
the precession however it is affected by
another another factor which is a slight
nod on the axis of the earth an odd but
not a wobble not a wobble a nod and and
it's called mutation and the the axis of
the earth nods back and forward over a
cycle of about 41,000 years and that can
that does adjust the position of sunrise
on the horizon over a very long period
of time and it would in theory if this
idea can be taken seriously enough it
would in theory be possible to use very
precise observations using the latest
modern tech not simply being up there in
a drone and seeing the general
connection between the position of the
Sun on the horizon
the head of serpent mound it would be
possible to refine that and actually say
astronomically the precise date on which
Serpent Mound must have been first
created to precisely target the Rising
Sun on the equinox well on that no we
just did three hours did we buy I would
I would ask your listeners and viewers
while we're talking about Ohio
don't forget about Newark and highbank
these are two incredible amazing
absolutely stunning gorgeous geometrical
sights
it's sad but one of them is preserved
within a private golf course Oh No
however it's not so sad because if it
hadn't been preserved within a private
golf course it would be gone completely
more than 90% of the Native American
earthworks that were documented in the
19th century are gone now they've been
plowed under for agriculture that's
another part of our missing story there
we're looking at Newark see that octagon
and circle combination that's repeated
at another site called highbank which is
60 miles away and the octagon circle
give me a large image of that so you see
all four layers that would it actually
that's what actually looks like that's a
graphic based on it well the octagon
circle combination in the top left of
the image are best preserved the other
bits are not so well preserved and the
reason the Octagon circle are best
preserved is cause they're in a private
Golf Club where otherwise they would
have been plowed under the interesting
thing is that that octagon circle
combination is 60 miles from high bank
but there's another octagon circle
combination there and it is oriented
that precisely 90 degrees to that one
that speaks of high science in the
Mississippi Valley a very very very long
time ago there's so much to explore and
so much to investigate and so much to
inquire into an America it's just an
incredible land and its mysteries have
been hidden from us and I'm hoping with
this book that I have managed to pull
the veil back a little bit on those
mysteries and if we're really coming to
the end of our thesis it really three
hours if we're really coming to the end
of our three hours can I repeat I would
love to see readers of my books at my
events I think three events in Canada
Vancouver Montreal and Toronto
and I'm doing something like 17 or 18
events in the United States I'm just
speaking continuously right the way
across the US I wish I could visit every
state in the US but my goodness this is
an enormous country every state in the
u.s. is as big as the entire British
Isles you know but I'm in visiting as
many as I am I'm going to be giving
Illustrated presentations I'll be
signing books afterwards I'll be taking
pictures I would like to meet my readers
and please check out my website Graham
Hancock com look at the talks and events
page and you'll see where all these
events are occurring over the next seven
weeks we're on the 22nd of April today I
will not leave North America until the
5th of June well I hope I see you again
then dissin thank you so much you're a
treasure and this book is I can't wait
to get into it America before and the
audiobook is available now as well yeah
the audio books available I'll read it
yeah thank you so much Graham it's
always a pleasure having you here I
really really appreciate you thanks for
having back on Joe Graham Hancock ladies
and gentlemen bye
[Applause]
[Music]